AGAIN WE HAVE SOME HOUSEKEEPING
THINGS WE NEED TO DO. I WILL GO
OVER THE STEPS WE'RE TAKING TO
PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE IN TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
ASSETS ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION
TO ENSURE MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA
PUBLIC HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
PROCEEDINGS TODAY THIS HEARING
WILL BE STREAMED ON THE
SOMEBODY'S WEBSITE AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC CAN PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN PERSON HERE IN ROOM
FOUR FOUR FOUR. OR VIA THE PHONE
. FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM.
FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM
WE'RE REQUIRING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SCENE PLEASE FOLLOW THE
DIRECTIONS OF OUR SERGEANTS AND
POSTED GUIDANCE. IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL. OR
THE INFORMATIONAL ITEM. I WILL
ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. A COPY OF THE AGENDA IS
AVAILABLE IN THE COMMITTEES ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. FOR
PEOPLE FOR PHONE TESTIMONY FOR
ANY MEMBERS OF PUBLIC THAT WILL
BE PROVIDING. COMMENT VIA
TELEPHONE WE ARE USING A
MODERATED PHONE SYSTEM THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. PLEASE
CALLING ON THE AUTHOR THE BILL
YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
BEGINS OUR PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE PHONE. ON THE
LINE GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE.
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MEETING YOUR LIVE
STREAM. HERE TO BUY THREE. SOUND
ISSUES. FINALLY I WANNA. THAT
THIS SIMPLY HAS EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISTRACTIONS TO THE
COMMITTEE OF PHARMACY IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS WE WILL ENSURE
THE ALL VOICES ARE HEARD HOWEVER
CONTACT THE DESTRUCTIVE STORMS
OR OHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION. TO THE FOLLOWING
WELL WE'RE- WHEN I WITH A SUPER
SUB COMMITTEE YEAH WE ARE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THAT WE COULD
HAVE OFFICERS YOU GOT OKAY OKAY
SO WE WILL BEGIN TODAY AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. MR FONG IN HIS. FIRST.
OKAY MISTER PUNK FUNK PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU SO MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
ELEVEN AS A LEGISLATIVE BILL
THAT WOULD CHANGE EVERY
REFERENCE TO THE OBSOLETE PAID
DELTA CONSERVATION PLAN TO A
MULTI SPECIES CONSERVATION PLAN
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN ADULT OF
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL CREATED
DELTA PLANT THIS PLAN DETAILS
POLICIES THAT NUMBERS
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ACHIEVE THE
COOLEY COOPER OF A MORE STATE
WATER SUPPLY. AND A HEALTHY
PROTECTED AMONG THE PLAN
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH THE
COMPLETION OF THE BAY DELTA
CONSERVATION PLAN OR BE DCP OVER
THE BAY DELTA CONSERVATION PLAN
WAS NEVER PUT INTO ACTION AS
FEDERAL AGENCIES HAVE NOT GIVEN
THE BAY DELTA CONSERVATION PLAN
CHOIR AUTHORIZATIONS AS A RESULT
LEGAL PROVISIONS INVOLVING THE
P. C. P. ARE OBSOLETE THIS BILL
GIVES ME BACK TO THESE LAWS BY
ENABLING THE RELEVANT GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES TO CREATE. A MULTI
SPECIESCONSERVATION. PLAN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. IN YOU. THANK YOU HAVE NO
SIMPLE WITNESSES CRACKED IN THE
WITNESSES OKAY THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY- WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
AND SUPPORT. K. OPERATOR COULD
WE GO TO THE PHONES PLEASE FOR
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AB ONE
DIFFERENCE APART OF A- IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT ONE
EIGHT ONE ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS THE
ONE AND THEN ZERO FAIR IN
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU SIR ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. SCENE NINE OPERATOR
WE PLEASE GO TO THE LINES. GIVE
IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN
ELEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR IN OPPOSITION. SAM
AND I'M SURE WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH. BRING
IT BACK TO THE- TWO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. I'D. THANK YOU
MANAGER PRODUCT FOR THE AUTHOR.
HELP US UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU
DEFINE AS MULTI SPECIES ET OR
WHAT THE INTENT IS WITHIN YOUR
THINKING. ON MULTI SPECIES. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO US A MEMBER
BIGELOW OF GREAT QUESTION RIGHT
NOW IN TERMS OF. FORTISBC THIS
BILL WHICH IS HELP WITH THE
SECRETARY FRAMEWORK- FOR TO
PROVIDE UPDATES FOR GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES TO PRESERVE AND RESTORE
ADULT AREAS- WITH A MULTI
SPECIES. CONSERVATION PLAN AND
TO CONTRIBUTE TO A MORE NATURAL
FLOW PATTERN- THEN THE EXISTING
CONDITIONS WITHIN THE DELTA. AT
ALSO IMPLEMENT A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE RESTORATION
PROGRAM. OKAY SO I JUST TRYING
TO GET BECAUSE SOMETIMES WE
DON'T THINK ABOUT IT BUT SPECIES
ARE ARE I NEED IS SOMEONE MAR
NEED TO TELL SOMEONE MORE WORMS-
THINGS THAT WE DON'T REALLY.
CARE PRICE IN OUR MINDS AS A AS
A SPECIES BUT HOW IN DEPTH. ARE
YOU REALLY LOOKING OR WHAT IS
THE INTENT OF THE BILLS ARE PER
VIEW OF. OF DEATH. THEY YOU SO
MUCH BIGELOW QUESTION IN TERMS
OF THE- THIS WAS JUST A LOT OF
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES SUCH AS THE
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE AND
OTHER STATE OR LOCAL AGENCIES
WITH JURISDICTION OVER THE
DELTA. A TO WORK ON THIS PLAN
AND IT WAS JUST A DIFFERENT MARK
JAMES A PLAN TO THE MULTI
SPECIES LOW COUNTRIES PLANT BUT
THE REST OF THE LAKE WHICH IS
NOT WHAT I REMAINED IN THE SAME.
SO YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
CURRENT WRITINGS OF THE BILL ARE
INCLUSIVE OF ALL OF THESE THINGS
ON IN TERMS OF THE CURRENT
WRITINGS OF THE BILL. THE DATE
OF THE CONSUMMATION PLAN
FEDERATIONS HIS AND NEVER
RECOGNIZED- THAT PLAN SO NOW.
WITH THIS PARTICULAR LANGUAGE
PROPOSED CHANGE WOULD ALLOW
FEDERAL AGENCIES AND OTHER FOLKS
TO WORK ON THE- THE SPATE OF THE
CONSERVATION PLAN DO YOU THINK
THAT BY AND MAKING THIS MORE
INCLUSIVE THIS MAKE. MAKE IT
PROHIBITIVE FOR ANYBODY TO EVER
DO ANYTHING BECAUSE THE COSTS
AND THE IMPACT OF HAVING TO
STUDY ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
I'VE MENTIONED A MORE THAT I
HAVEN'T MENTIONED. I TERMS OF.
THE IMPACT DON'T THINK IT'S
GOING TO MAKE ANY. ADDITIONAL
AND TAXES PRETTY MUCH ALLOWS A
CHANGE OF THE LETTER. THE
LANGUAGE TO. THE SPOT A SPECIES
CONSERVATION PLAN TO CHANGE THE
FROM THE BATTLEFIELD- SOMME.
LANGUAGE WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO
ENTERTAIN AMENDMENT LANGUAGE- AS
THIS BILL PROGRESSES THAT WOULD
STIPULATE TO THAT THAT HE WOULD
NOT CAUSE. ADDITIONAL IMPACTS.
BY HAVING THIS ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE I YES A BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS OKAY. THANK YOU FOR
THAT THANK YOU SOMEONE. EIGHTY
EIGHT IN THE OTHER MEMBERS HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. WHEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I THINK
IT'S A MUCH MANAGER MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NEIGHBORHOOD THANK YOU. WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL MOVE YOUR
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER PRIME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON ARE YOU
READY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
T. THREE ALTERNATIVE PROJECT
DELIVERY METHODS. AS CLIMATE
CHANGE INTENSIFIES DROUGHT
CONDITIONS IN OUR STATE THIS
LEGISLATION WILL EXPEDITE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A REGIONAL
RECYCLED WATER PROJECT AND A SET
OF DROUGHT RESPONSE PROJECTS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WITH ME IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE ON THE PHONE IS JOHN
KONARSKI OF ON BEHALF OF
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
MEMBER CULT MEMBER CALDERON CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. YES OKAY THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JOHN BEDNARSKI I AM THE
MANAGER OF ENGINEERING SERVICES
AT METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE THE SPONSORS OF AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE. MISTER PAUL TO THE
REGIONAL WHOLESALER THAT
DELIVERS WATER TO TWENTY SIX
MEMBER AGENCIES SERVING ABOUT
NINETEEN MILLION PEOPLE AND
LOCAL BUSINESSES IN LOS ANGELES
ORANGE RIVERSIDE SAN BERNARDINO.
SAN DIEGO AND VENTURA COUNTIES.
CALIFORNIA IS IN YEAR THREE OF A
WORSENING DROUGHT. SHRINKING
ALLOCATIONS FROM THE STATE WATER
PROJECT AND THE FIRST EVER WATER
SHORTAGE DECLARED ON THE
COLORADO RIVER HAVE LAID BARE
THE LONG TERM RISKS OF DROUGHT
ON SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S WATER
SUPPLY. IN RESPONSE METROPOLITAN
IS WORKING TO EXPEDITE THE NEW
DROUGHT PROOF SUPPLY OF WATER
AND A SET OF EMERGENCY
MITIGATION PROJECTS TO MAKE OUR
REGIONAL DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM
MORE RESILIENT. AND ADAPTIVE AND
ABLE TO ADAPT TO THE REALITIES
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. AS THE PUBLIC
AGENCY WE ARE CURRENTLY LIMITED
TO TRADITIONAL DESIGN BID BUILD
MODEL FOR THE DELIVERY OF PUBLIC
WORKS CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS.
THIS METHODOLOGY CAN BE
INEFFICIENT AND INFLEXIBLE FOR
LARGE TIME SENSITIVE AND COMPLEX
PROJECTS LIKE LIKE THE ONES THAT
WE HAVE PLANNED. METROPOLITAN IS
SEEKING AUTHORIZATION TO USE
THREE ADDITIONAL PROJECT
DELIVERY MODELS THAT WILL
ENHANCE OUR ABILITY TO DELIVER
KEY WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS IN AN EFFICIENT AND
TIMELY MANNER. THE ENHANCED
DELIVERY OF PROJECTS AND
IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR EXISTING
FACILITIES IS CRITICAL TO OUR
REGION AND THE MANY WATER
AGENCIES AND BUSINESSES THAT
DEPEND UPON METROPOLITAN TO
DELIVER A HIGH QUALITY RELIABLE
SUPPLY. COLLABORATIVE
CONTRACTING METHODS LIKE DESIGN
BUILD PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BUILD
AND CONSTRUCTION MANAGER GENERAL
CONTRACTOR ON LARGE SCALE
PROJECTS LIKE OURS WOULD ALLOW
PROJECTS TO AVOID DELAYS AND CAN
REDUCE RISKS AND OVERALL COST TO
RATE PAYERS. THE PROJECT THAT
WOULD BENEFIT FROM ALTERNATIVE
DELIVERY INCLUDING. THE REGIONAL
RECYCLED WATER PROGRAM A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN METROPOLITAN
AND THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT TO CREATE A
NEW LOCAL WATER SUPPLY ENOUGH TO
SERVE MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOMES. AND SEVERAL
DROUGHT MITIGATION PROJECTS TO
INSTALL NEW PUMP STATIONS AND
MAKE UPGRADES TO OUR
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM SO THAT WE
CAN MOVE LOCAL WATER SUPPLIES.
TO PARTS OF OUR SERVICE AREA
THAT ARE CURRENTLY WHOLLY
DEPENDENT ON STATE WATER PROJECT
IMPORT. IN CLOSING I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN HELPING TO
MAINTAIN A RELIABLE SUPPLY OF
WATER PERCENT IN CALIFORNIA AND
FOR INTRODUCIN AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE. ON BEHALF OF
METROPOLITAN ARE TWENTY SIX
MEMBER AGENCIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. FOR THEIR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE ROOM TODAY. MEDICARE
MEMBERS OPERATE WITH GREEN
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON BEHALF
OF THE WATER REPLENISHMENT
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. FOR THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT WITNESSES. OKAY WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONES. OPERATOR
SUPPORT WHICH IS. THANK YOU IF
YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS THE ONE AND THEN THEIR
APPEARANCE A PART OF AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STAFF
A LOT SO ON BEHALF OF INLAND
EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY IN
CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WHAT THE
YEAH. AND WE DO HAVE A FEW
QUEUING UP MOMENT HERE- LINE
NUMBERS. AGAIN WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. FORTY FIVE. WE'RE GONNA
LINE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JACK WALKER
WITH THE CORE GROUP ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL THAT CAN BALANCE
INSTEAD OF THE MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE. NINE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
THIRTEEN YEAR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MANAGER WILL ON TO A TWENTY
SEVEN YOU LINE IS A PLEASE AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
THIS IS GUARANTEED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
SAYS HE AND- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WILL GO THE LINE SIX
ALIGN ITSELF PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- J. SENATE MAKERS ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICTS ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND LINE AT
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE UNDER AVERAGE OUT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION AND WE
SUPPORT AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NOT FOR THE SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MOVING BACK TO THE ROOM IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
TODAY. THANK YOU OPERATOR
COMMITMENT TO THE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OF
AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
NO ONE AND THEN THEY OFFER
OPPOSITION OF AB. EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE. BEN MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. OF COURSE. WE
NEED TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WE
DO. AT THE START MORE. RIGHT
COMMAGER NINETEEN OH **** YEAH
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS MISTER BENNETT
THANK YOU YEAH I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO COMPLEMENT THE OFFICER- THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF RECYCLING IS JUST
GOING TO BE ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL- AS WE MAKE THIS
TRANSITION FROM. TEMPORARY
DROUGHTS TO PERMANENT
CHARACTERIZATION OPTICALLY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- SO IT'S
JUST GREAT TO HAVE- IN THE V. D.
ON BOARD- WITH YOUR EFFORTS AND
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO PUSH FOR
THANK YOU. MISTRIAL QUESTION MR
GREEN IS RIGHT OUTSIDE. IF YOU
COULD JUST CALL FOR HIS. OKAY
ARE YOU HAVING IT HAPPEN OKAY
THEN WOULD BE ABLE TO MOVE. CAN
GET MR LEVINE PLEASE. THANK.
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. DOLLY HERE
NAZARIAN BENNETT BIGELOW
FRIEDMAN GARCIA KALRA LEVINE
MURATSUCHI WHEN RUBIO. SALAS
SMITH. VIP DO HERE. WARD THANK
YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM. THIS
CALDERON WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE AT
YES THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NAY VOTE. L. SEVEN
MOTION AND A SECOND CALL THE
ROLL. DALY NOBODY DALY NOT
VOTING NAZARIAN. BENNETT BENNETT
I BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING
FRIEDMAN. GARCIA GARCIA I KALRA
LEVINE. LEVINE AYE MURATSUCHI
AND WHEN RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS I SMITH. THE APPROVED WHAT
THE APPROVED WHAT I WARD. THE
BILL'S ON CALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. HI I DON'T WANT I DON'T
WANT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE. EVAN
MOTION ON M. A. B. EIGHTEEN
ELEVEN. WE NEED A SECOND PROGRAM
IS GARCIA THANK YOU. COLORADO.
DALY NO DOLLING NO NAZARIAN
BENNETT. BENNETT I BIGELOW
BIGELOW NOW FRIEDMAN GARCIA
GARCIA I KALRA LEVIN LEVINE I'M
MURATSUCHI. NO ONE RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SALAS. SALAS. OKAY SMITH.
THE PRODUCER. WARD. AT SEVEN
CALLS ABOUT. YES FOCAL REPORTER
SOME BILLS ON CALL OKAY NEXT I
SEE MR WOOD IN THE ROOM. OH
SORRY RAMOS THANK. IT SEEMS.
OKAY.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE'RE HERE TO
PRESENT ON AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
JOINED HERE WITH MY- JOINT
AUTHORS- CRISTINA GARCIA AB
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WOULD PROHIBIT
THE WORD- A DEROGATORY NAME
TOWARDS NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN-
WE CAUGHT THE S. WORD BILL BUT
I'LL SAY THE WORDS SO THAT
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE COULD
UNDERSTAND TRULY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE WORD THIS
DEROGATORY TO NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN IS THE WORD SQUAW. NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN ARE THE PILLARS
OF NATIVE AMERICAN FAMILIES-
BRINGING STABILITY AND RESPECT
TO ALL OF OUR PEOPLE THIS WORD
IS STILL BEING USED IN WELL OVER
ONE HUNDRED GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS
PUTTING A GREAT DISSERVICE TO
THE THOUSANDS OF WOMEN AND
CHILDREN IN THE STATE IT IS MY
BELIEF THAT THIS WORD REFLECTS
THE ATTITUDE TOWARDS THE
TREATMENT OF NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN WHERE THIS BODY HAS HEARD
ME SPEAK TO THE ISSUE OF MISSING
AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN.
WHEN WE SEE THE MENTALITY BACK
IN THESE DAYS AND USING THESE
TYPES OF TERMS ONLY PRESENTS THE
MENTALITY AND THE PERCEPTION OF
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN AS LESS
THAN EQUAL TO OTHERS INDIGENOUS
WOMEN ARE CURRENTLY COMES OF
MURDER RATES MORE THAN TEN TIMES
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE IN THIS.
SPECT DEMONSTRATED AGAINST
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN THIS BILL
REQUIRES EVERY STATE AGENCY
LOCAL GOVERNING BODY AND
POLITICAL SUBDIVISIONS IN THE
STATE TO IDENTIFY ALL GEOGRAPHIC
SITES PUBLIC LANDS WATERS AND
STRUCTURES UNDER HIS
JURISDICTION TO CONTAINING THIS
RACIAL TERMS AB TWENTY TWENTY
TWO ESTABLISHES A PROCEDURE TO
ELICIT INPUT AND RENAME
LOCATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED. SELECTING
REPLACEMENT NAMES A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS STATE AGENCIES IN
THE CALIFORNIA ADVISORY
COMMITTEE SHALL SOLICIT INPUT
FROM TRIBES MAINTAINED ON THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN-HERITAGE COMMISSION LIST. TODAY
I ALSO HAVE WITH ME TO TESTIFY
DANIELLE FRANK FROM THE NATIVE
SISTER CIRCLE AND MORNING STAR
GALI OF THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
COMPONENT. THIS IS A AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO MOVE
FORWARD AS A LEGISLATURE IS
START TO CORRECT SOME OF THESE
DEROGATORY NAMES AND THE
MENTALITY OF PERCEPTION TOWARDS
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN I WOULD
ALSO NOW LIKE TO- HAVE MY JOINT
CO AUTHOR CRISTINA GARCIA SAY A
FEW WORDS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRS AND MEMBER I AM HUMBLED
TO BE HERE WITH MISTER ROMMEL'S
AND OUR WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AS THE
CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
WORKING TO EMPOWER ALL WOMEN IN
BEING INCLUSIVE HAS BEEN A PARTY
FOR MYSELF. OUT HERE AND EXCITED
THAT WE GET TO WORK ON THIS BILL
TOGETHER THE S. WORD IS A RACIST
AND MISOGYNISTIC. OSTLER THE
TERM IS USED BY EARLY CALIFORNIA
SETTLERS AND ACCOUNTS OF BRUTAL
RAPE AND SLAVE MAN AND GENOCIDE
OF NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN GIRLS
AND COMMUNITIES. THAT ARE OVER A
HUNDRED YOUR GRAPHIC FEATURES
AND PLACES NAMES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT INCLUDE THE S. WORD. OUT
THERE. THE SAD REALITY IS THAT
THE TERM HAS BEEN USED FOR
GENERATIONS AND IT'S BEEN
NORMALIZED. EVEN THOUGH IT'S A
MASSAGE AND RACIST TERM ROOTED
IN THE OPPRESSION OF BELITTLING
OF INDIGENOUS WOMEN. THE BILL
BEGINS TO CORRECT AN UGLY AND
PEOPLE PART OF OUR HISTORY BY
REMOVING IT FROM CALIFORNIA
LANDMARKS. IT'S ELISE IT CAN DO
TO HELP OUR INDIGENOUS WOMEN
HEEL OUT THERE BUT IT'S REALLY
JUST ONE STEP OF MANY WE NEED TO
DO IN ORDER TO GAIN REAL
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. OUT THERE
ON COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT WORK AND WHEN TIME IS
APPROPRIATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. MISS
FRANK WOULD YOU LIKE TO START.
HE- WE DO THING YOUR WHOLE AREA
HELLO MY NAME IS DANIEL FRANK
I'M AN ENROLLED MEMBER OF THE
GROUP A TRIBE AS WELL AS THE
YOUTH COORDINATOR AT SAVE
CALIFORNIA SALMON. I WANT TO
START OFF BY SAYING I'M HONORED
TO BE HERE AS AN ADVOCATE FOR MY
PEOPLE AND WOMEN JUST LIKE ME
TODAY WE'RE HERE TO EXPLAIN THAT
THE S. WORD IS IN NO WAY A
COMPLIMENT OR TRIBUTE TO
INDIGENOUS WOMEN ALTHOUGH IT IS
A DEROGATORY TERM. WITH A LONG
HISTORY OF GLORIFYING THE SEXUAL
ABUSE THAT ONE INTO INDIGENOUS
WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY STILL FACE
TODAY. TO NAME OUR LANDS AND
WATERS AFTER ADJOURNMENT TO DE
HUMANIZE THE INDIGENOUS WOMEN IS
THE BIGGEST INSULT TO THE
ORIGINAL HOUSE INHABITANTS OF
THAT LAND THAT I CAN IMAGINE.
ALL WE ARE ASKING IS THAT THE
INDIGNITIES THAT INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE FACE IN THIS DAY EVERY
DAY. BE LESSENED AND THAT ARE
NATIVE BROTHERS AND SISTERS ARE
ABLE TO FEEL AT HOME ON THEIR
ANCESTRAL LAND. TOGETHER WE CAN
MAKE CALIFORNIA A PLACE WHERE
THE NATIVE COMMUNITY FEELS AT
HOME BECAUSE WE ARE. HELP US
RECTIFY THE WRONGS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS COMMITTED AGAINST
ITS NATIVE POPULATION. THIS IS
THE BEGINNING OF A LONG JOURNEY
OF MUCH NEEDED HEALING FOR
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE. I
WOULD LIKE TO PERSONALLY THANK
MEMBER RAMOS THE NUMBER GARCIA
FOR. FIRST FOUR I WOULD LIKE TO
PERSONALLY THINK ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA FOR
INTRODUCING AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND SPEAKING UP FOR INDIGENOUS
AND JUSTICE I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE TO THE
MEMBERS FOR LISTENING TO US TELL
OUR PERSPECTIVE. I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO TAKE OUR TESTIMONIES INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN TIME COMES
AND LET THEM GUIDE YOU INTO
SAYING YES TO AB TWENTY TWENTY
TWO SET YET THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THIS GOLLY. JAMISON WAY MY
NAME IS MORNING STAR GALLEY AND
I'M A MEMBER OF THE CHING MOLLY
TRY- AUTOMOTIVE OF THE RIVER TRY
. I AS PROJECT DIRECTOR FOR
JUSTICE FOR INDIGENOUS PEOPLES
AND WE ARE HONORED TO HELP TO
YOU A CO SPONSOR AB TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS INDIGENOUS JUSTICE
ADVOCATES WE ARE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
FOR CO AUTHORING. THE REMOVAL OF
THE S. WORD THAT'S WHAT IS AN
EPITHET THAT HAS HISTORIC TIES
TO RACISM AND SEXUALISATION OF
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN IT IS A
TERM THAT IS DEHUMANIZING
DEVALUING AND DEROGATORY. IT IS
A RACIAL SLUR THAT IS CULTURALLY
DEMEANING AND DEGRADING TO
NATIVE WOMEN. THOSE THERE ARE
THOSE THAT WILL WANT TO ARGUE
THAT THE SLUR SOMEHOW SHOWING
RESPECT FOR US BUT AS INDIGENOUS
WOMEN WE ARE RIGHT FOR BEFORE
YOU EXPLAINING TO YOU THAT THIS
WORD IS NOT RESPECTFUL. IT'S THE
SAME ARGUMENT WE HAVE
ENCOUNTERED WITH RACIST AND
DEGRADING MASCOTS THEY WILL SAY
THAT WE'RE HONORING WITH YOU
WITH CARTOON CHARACTERS IT IS
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND WE ARE NO
LONGER STANDING FOR THAT INSULT.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO SHIFTING THE
NARRATIVE TOWARDS TRUTH TELLING
AND RACIAL JUSTICE JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA AS A STATE WAS
FOUNDED ON STATE SPONSORED
GENOCIDE. IT IS TIME NOW TO TAKE
MEASURES TO RECTIFY THE WRONGS
THAT HAVE BEEN COMMITTED. THIS
IS A STEP. IN AND JUST FOR TWO.
AND PEOPLE. AND FOR ON EIGHT
AMERICAN PEOPLE'S THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO
ONE ACT THE FOLLOWING TO
IDENTIFY ALL PLACES WHERE THIS
WORD IS USED. FOR PLACE NAMES IN
CALIFORNIA TO ESTABLISH A
PROCESS. FOR STATE AGENCIES AND
LOCAL GOVERNING BODIES TO
IDENTIFY THE NAMES. PRIORITIZING
TRAVEL IN PART AND TO PROHIBIT
THE USE OF THE WORD IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR
WORDS AND WHERE RESPECTFULLY
ASKING YOU TO VOTE YES. AB
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND SET AN
EXAMPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT INDIAN COUNTRY SUCH A
LADY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS AND OUR SORRY PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT AND THE ROOM TODAY. JUST
COME TO THE MICROPHONE. A MILE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
LISA GALLIE REVERBNATION IN REAL
TROUBLE MEMBER OF THE ACHOUR
BAND IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU YOU. MY
NAME IS ELIANA MASUDA FROM THE
MEANWHILE I OWN TEN. AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU. SANTA MONICA CA HELLO
MY NAME IS ANGELINA HOSA SIX
YEARS OLD AND I'M SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WELL YEAH WE
MY NAME IS APRIL MIGUEL I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM FOR URBAN INDIAN
HEALTH I'M ALSO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF AMERICAN INDIAN
CULTURAL CENTER IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M ON AND ROLLED MEMBER OF
ROUND VALLEY AND YOU KEY AND
MUTUAL WAFFLE AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
WILL HEY IT'S NOT A CENTER MATEO
HEY- MY NAME IS NICOLE WHIPPLE
I. AGREED THIS MORNING AND-
THREE OF MY LANGUAGES. I AM.
POMO YOU KEY IN MY DO. AND I AM
FROM AROUND VALIANT BE IN TRIBES
AND I'M HERE TO IN SUPPORT. OF
AB TWENTY TWENTY TO. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. SANTA MONICA MY
NAME'S WITH THE C. OCULAR INTO
LEVEL MONDAY. I'M A MEMBER OF ON
THE PANEL EVIL TRIBE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND FOUNDER OF NATIVE
SISTER CIRCLE YOUTH GROUP HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
CATHOLIC THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
BELL CONTRARY I AM A ROAD OF
THAT OWN BAND WALKING- I WOULD
HAVE I TELL ROLL INTO HEALTH BY
FOR TEN YEARS AND I AM SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWO TWO THANK YOU.
WHEN SAX RESIDENT OF MENDOCINO
CO. CITIZEN OF NATION. AND I TO
WOMEN'S. OF. TWENTY TWENTY.
RIGHT. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JAMES RESTS ON MIDDLE MEMBERS
AROUND ON INDIAN TRIBES HI MOST
OF THE TROUBLE CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA
INDIAN TRIBES AND I ALSO SUPPORT
TWENTY TWO TWENTY OR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU THANK.
HELLO RANDALL BRADEN- AND ROLLED
MEMBER ROUND VALLEY INDIAN
TRIBES ALSO ARAMBULA LEADING
TRIBAL COUNCIL MEMBER I'M HERE
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. CABLE TO
THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR IN
SUPPORT. GIFFORD SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS THE ONE AND THEN THEY
OFFERED SUPPORT. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME BUT THEY'RE
MOSTLY MADE FROM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE ONLINE SUPPORT
COMING UP COLOR AND WE'RE
COSPONSORED IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
NEXT OVER THE LINE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM BIGELOW. HELLO MY NAME IS THE TO BACK
ON A RED OF AN THROUGHOUT NINE
THREE SIX FIVE EAST OF FRESNO
AND I'M- A MEMBER OF THE
RESIDENTS FOR RENAMING SQUAW
VALLEY I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS BOB MCCLOSKEY I
LIVE IN A VALLEY NINE THREE SIX
SEVEN FIVE AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO THANK.
THANK YOU NEXT OVER LINE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SCOTT GOVERNOR BEHALF OF THE
MORONGO BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO BOTTOM LINE THIRTY SIXTY
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING COMMITTEE
BRAD WILLIAMS ON THE ACLU CARE
ACT IN OUTLOOK BONTA AB TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU KNOCKED ON THE LINE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS REGINA
CHICAGOLAND WITH A CALIFORNIA
SALMON COMING FROM- ORLEANS
CALIFORNIA GROUP PLAN TO NINE
REPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING AND EXCELLING AT
WITH BECOME FAMILY I A HOMEOWNER
AND PAY. AND I AM. THANK YOU
NEXT TO LINE THIRD ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS BEAR
TAYLOR I LIVE AND- S. VALLEY AND
FRESNO COUNTY AND I AM A MEMBER
OF THE GROUP RESIDENTS FOR
RENAMING THAT'S VALLEY WE ARE
NOT INDIGENOUS BUT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO LINE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JUNE TAYLOR AND I'M A RESIDENT
OF S. WORD VALLEY IN FRESNO
COUNTY AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
RESIDENTS FROM RENAMING- IN THIS
TOWN AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTED YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM TODAY.
OPERATOR TO MOVE TO THE PHONES
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN OPPOSITION AND
WE ARE ON A B. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN Q. THANK YOU BRING
IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. OF INS.
IN SUPPORT. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FRANK MOLINA IN STRONG SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF SALMON WILL BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS AND THE SENATORS
AND THIS A CHUMASH INDIANS
PARDON MY TARDINESS THANK YOU. A
GOOD MORNING BUDDY MY NAME IS
OMAIR FOOT SENIOR I'M
REPRESENTED FOR THE RUN BY THE
TRIBES- COUNCILMEMBER. AND I'D
AGAIN STRONG SUPPORT AB TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BECAUSE WE'RE ALL THE
PEOPLE OUTSIDE I'M ALLOW IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE THAT WANTS
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. BECAUSE I
KNOW WE'VE BEEN CHAPLAIN PEOPLE
IN AND OUT SO. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE THAT WANTS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT THAT WE MISSED. OKAY
THANK YOU BACK THE MEMBERS. WE
HAVE A MOTION AS OPPOSED. I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU FOR THE BILL
THANK YOU ALSO FOR EDUCATING US
I THINK SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
OBLIVIOUS TO THIS BUT THAT
DOESN'T MAKE USING THA TERM
CORRECT SO I JUST I THINK IT'S
AN MPORTANT AND BRAVE- TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE'S EDUCATED
PROPERLY THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
SWING- WHICH I TO CLOSE MISTER.
FIRST OF. THE YOU AND- IT TO THE
WITNESSES- SAYING HERE YOUR
HEARING FIRST HAND WHAT THE
WE'RE TRULY DOES MEAN. TO THE
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN NOT ONLY
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BUT ACROSS THE NATION- ONE OF
THANK YOU TWO MIGHT JOIN AUTHOR-
CRISTINA GARCIA. AND ALSO- WOULD
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. I THINK THIS IS
MY GRATITUDE JERRY THAT CAME TO
TESTIFY TO VERY AND THE
CONTINUOUS EDUCATION. OF AROUND
IS WORTH MATTER. THE MATTER FOR
A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS AND- IT'S
TIME THAT WE BEGIN THAT HEALING
PROCESS AND WE SHOULD THE
RESPECT THAT IT HAS BEEN LONG
OVERDUE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS DOLLY BY DELHI I
NAZARIAN BENNETT. BENNETT I
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE KALRA
KALRA I. LEVINE LEVINE I'M
MURATSUCHI WHEN RUBIO RUBIO AYE
SALAS SALAS I SMITH. THE PADUCAH
THE FOOD WHILE I WARD WARD I.
REALLY THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NOW WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CORRECT.
THE ITEMS ON CONSENT TODAY OUR
AB TWO TWO FOUR EIGHT AB ONE
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN AB ONE EIGHT
SIX FIVE AND AB TWO NINE SEVEN
FIVE. WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DALY HI
DALY AYE NAZARIAN. BENNETT
SENATE I BIGELOW. FRIEDMAN HI.
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA I
KALRA. LEVINE LEVINE AYE
MURATSUCHI NEWMAN. RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SALAS SALAS AYE AYES SMITH.
THE APPROVED BY THE FOOD WHILE I
WARD WARD I. LEAVE THAT OPEN
FOR. MEMBERS TO ADD ON. MISTER
WOULD.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
PROPERS IN AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
ONE. THANK YOU. BUT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT BEING PROACTIVE SOMETHING
WE DON'T ALWAYS DO WELL IN
GOVERNMENT. ONLY THE WATER BOARD
HAS NO FULL TIME STAFF DEDICATED
TO DROUGHT PLANNING AND
RESPONSE. THIS MEANS THAT WHEN
DROUGHT STRIKES THE GOVERNOR
DECLARES EMERGENCY AND THE BOARD
TEMPORARILY ASSIGNS EXISTING
STAFF TO THESE DUTIES FOR THE
DURATION OF THE EMERGENCY. ABA
MACBOOK BECAUSE IT MEANS WE ARE
BEING REACTIONARY BECAUSE
RIPPLING STAFF AWAY FROM THEIR
DAY JOBS EVEN OTHER IMPORTANT
WORK UNDERSTAFFED. THE FIRST
ELEMENT OF THIS BILL ADDRESSES
THAT THAT DYNAMIC BY CREATING A
DEDICATED DROUGHT UNIT WITHIN
THE DIVISION OF WATER RIGHTS AT
THE WATER BOARD. SECOND THE BILL
ESTABLISHES A PILOT PROJECT IN
SOME OF THE STATE'S MOST
CRITICAL SALMON AND STEELHEAD
BEARING WATERSHEDS. THE PILOT
DIRECTS THE WATER BOARD TO
PREPARE DROUGHT CONTINGENCY
PLANS FOR SUCCESS FOR SELECT
COASTAL WATERSHEDS THAT ARE
PRIORITY FISH BEARING STREAMS
AND CURRENTLY LACK MEANINGFUL
WATER MANAGEMENT PLANS. THE GOAL
OF THIS POWERS TO CREATE A
BALANCE OF INCENTIVES AND
REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL HELP
WATER USERS. IN SELECT WATERSHED
UPDATE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
USER USAGE PATTERNS AND BE MORE
PREPARED FOR THE EXTENDED
DROUGHT PERIODS THAT HAVE BECOME
ALL TOO FAMILIAR. ULTIMATELY
THESE CONTINGENCY PLANS WILL
CREATE TRANSPARENCY.
PREDICTABILITY AND RESILIENCY
DURING TIMES OF SEVERE DROUGHT.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CORRECTLY CAPTURE THE
APPROPRIATE WATERSHEDS FOR THIS
PILOT. AND WE GIVE THE BOARD
CLEAR DIRECTION ABOUT THE KINDS
OF INCENTIVES AND PARTNERSHIPS
WE WANT TO SEE IN THIS PILOT
PROGRAM. I'M COMMITTED TO THIS
IS A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS AND
GRATEFUL FOR THE CONTINUED WORK
BY STAKEHOLDERS ON ALL SIDES.
AND DETERMINED IT TO ENSURE THAT
WE GET THE RIGHT MIX OF
INCENTIVES IN THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD. MEMBERS LAST YEAR I
WORKED ON LEGISLATION THAT ADDED
CAPACITY TO CAL FIRE TO START
PREPARING FOR THE NEXT FIRE
BEFORE IT STARTS BURNING. IT'S
PAST TIME THAT WE START
PREPARING FOR THE NEXT DROUGHT.
BEFORE IT STOPS RAINING. HERE TO
TESTIFY N SUPPORT R. J. IS JAY
ZIGGLER- IN THAT NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND BRIAN JOHNSON
WITH TROUT UNLIMITED MAY BE ON
THE PHONE BECAUSE I DON'T SEE
HIM BUT- IN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SAID
THANK YOU- AM J. ZIEGLER THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
ONE- IT IS TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD NOTES TO MANAGE WATER- BUT
FOR THE BENEFIT OF PEOPLE
AGRICULTURE AND WILDLIFE- AS WE
FACE- CONTINUED PATTERNS OF
DROUGHT- IT IS WORTH NOTING
THAT- RIVERS ON THE NORTH COAST
RAND DRYING AND THIS PAST YEAR
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN RECORDED
HISTORY. AND WE CERTAINLY SEE
WATER DEMAND ACCELERATING- ALL
AROUND US THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND IT'S TIME TO ACTUALLY PLAN
TO USE THE WATER IN THESE- WATER
SETS MORE WISELY- FOR THE
BENEFIT- OF ALL STAKEHOLDERS. WE
WOULD NOTE THAT AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY ONE WILL BILL THE CENTRAL
CAPACITY AT THE STATE BOARD- TO
ADDRESS DROUGHT AHEAD OF- ITS
OCCURRENCE AND INSTEAD PLANNED
METHODICALLY. AS DOCTOR WOULD
NOTES TO PUT THE RIGHT FRAMEWORK
OF INCENTIVES IN PLACE TO APPLY
THE BEST SCIENCE TO PLAN FOR
DIVERSIONS WHEN WATER IS
ABUNDANT AND RIVER SYSTEMS- TO
LAY OFF THE STREAMS WHEN WATER
IS LESS ABUNDANT FOR NATURE- AND
TO REPORT ON ACT OUTCOMES AND
ADAPTIVELY MANAGE IN A WAY THAT
SETS AN EXAMPLE- OF- WATERSHED
MANAGEMENT WATER HEALTH- THAT
WILL TRULY BENEFIT. PEOPLE AND
NATURE ABOUT HOW- WEADAPT TO
CHANGING- HYDROLOGIC CONDITIONS
DRIVEN BY CLIMATE CHANGE- THEN
IN CLOSING I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT- WE SEE THAT- THIS
FRAMEWORK WILL BUILD ESSENTIAL
CAPACITY AT THE BOARD- TO HAVE
MORE RELIABLE ACCESSIBLE AND
TRANSPARENT. PLANNING THAT WILL
BENEFIT ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND- WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU. AN
OPERATOR CAN WE SEE IF- MR
JOHNSON IS ON THE LINE FOR
PRIMARY WITNESS. IN SUPPORT-
JOHNSON IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE
YOU MAY PRESS THE STAR. ZERO
OKAY WILL MOVE BACK TO THE
SENATE HEARING ROOM IS THERE-
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TODAY.
ON. TWENTY FOUR FIFTY ONE. K.
OPERATOR WILL MOVE TO THE PHONES
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT ITS
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
ONE THAT ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO LINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ALEX GUERRERO I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CAL TROUT
AND AS- OF THE BILL WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MONEY WITHOUT
WOMEN I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE ENVIRONMENT DEFENSE FUND THE
MONO LAKE COMMITTEE. AND
CALIFORNIANS ARNOLD VOTERS
FORMALLY FEEL PEAS BEANS ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO BOTTOM
LINE OF FORTY SIXTY LINE IS OPEN
. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KIM
DELFINO AND I'M CALLING IN ON
THE BEHALF OF BOTTOM LINE
CALIFORNIA DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
AND THE NOMA MANTRA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KNOCKED OVER LINE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME'S KRISTY
ABOUT MEN HI MATT GILROY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT LINE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM
AND I'M SURE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM TODAY.
OPERATOR WILL MOVE TO THE PHONES
IN OPPOSITION. GIVE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND
THEN THEIR FAN UP POSITION. AND
THEN I'M SURE WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THINK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK TO MEMBERS
FOR ANY QUESTIONS HOUSE. YES
MOST READ THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD I JUST
CAN'T BELIEVE IT HAS BEEN DONE
ALREADY- CONSIDERING THE AMOUNT
OF JOBS THAT I'VE HAD IN
CALIFORNIA SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL WOULD LOVE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SELF. ANY OTHER
MEMBERS. CAPE MISTER WHAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
DOLLY NOBODY DALY NOT VOTING
NAZARIAN. BENNETT BENNETT I
BIGELOW FRIEDMAN. GARCIA. GARCIA
I KALRA. LEVINE MURATSUCHI. AND
WHEN RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS ICE SMITH. THE BUDDHA B.
VALLAPUDUA I WARD WARD I. SURE
I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS CO
AUTHOR ALSO WITH OUR EVER YOU
I'LL TAKE A STEP BACK. THE TEST
RIGHT AWAY HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR. A THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISS REAVIS. BY SHARE GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES.
THE SO I'M HERE THIS MORNING TO
BE A SOME BILL TWO ONE ZERO
EIGHT WHICH SEEKS TO ELEVATE THE
VOICES OF COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
WATER POLICY- SOME DECISIONS- BY
SHOWING THAT WE DESIGNATE ONE
SEAT ON THE STATE AND REGIONAL
WATER BOARDS- TO BE FILLED BY AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE OR TRIBAL-
A COMMUNITY MEMBER. HAS
LEGISLATION ALSO SEEKS TO
INCORPORATE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ANALYSIS INTO THE
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR MAJOR FOR
MAJOR WATER PERMITS. THIS YEAR
MARKS THE FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE PASSAGE OF THE FEDERAL
CLEAN WATER ACT- AND ON THIS
FIFTIETH YEAR ANNIVERSARY MANY
LOW INCOME- SO COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR STILL LACK ACCESS TO CLEAN
WATER. MANY OF THESE UNDERSERVED
AND UNDER RESOURCE- SOME
COMMUNITIES ARE HOME TO LOCAL
WORKERS- AND THEIR FAMILIES WHO
LACK THE RESOURCES LACK THE TIME
AND THE ACCESS TO ADVOCATE
AGAINST POLICIES THAT HARM THE
COMMUNITIES RESULTING IN SOME
DECADES OF NEGLECT. CURRENTLY
THERE ARE NO SEATS RESERVED FOR
A MEMBER FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE OR TRAVEL COMMUTE BROWN
ON OUR STATE WATER BOARDS. AND
WELL THE CURRENT BOARD HAS TAKEN
PROACTIVE STEPS. TO IMPROVE
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE OUTCOMES BUT
WE MUST ENSURE THAT OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE MOVING
FORWARD. ADDITIONALLY THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD REQUIRE
COMMUNITY OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE
POLICY CONSIDERATIONS FOR
SIGNIFICANT WATER PERMITS THAT
THE STATE AND REGIONAL WATER. A
WITH ME HERE TO TEST OF IN WOULD
BE L. SAW THE BAR BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND SHAUN
BOTHWELL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COAST KEEP RELIANCE. WHO'S ALSO
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IN WITH THAT THANK
YOU. MATTER MUCH. THANK YOU. FOR
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS MY NAME WE
HAD SOME ABOUT NOT WITH THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER- AND WE
ARE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ONES ARE A BY A RIVAS BECAUSE
THIS BILL A CRITICAL TOOL FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE MANY OF WHICH WE HAVE
WORKED ALONGSIDE WITH FOR
DECADES TO ADDRESS DEEP WATER
AND EQUITIES- SPECIFICALLY AB
TWENTY ONE ZERO EIGHT WILL
ENSURE THAT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WILL HAVE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE DURING. POLICY
DECISIONS. AUDIBLE ALSO HAVE A
REPORT. ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE
STUDIES IMPACT. ANALYSIS AND
BOTH OF THESE MEASURES ALONG
WITH THE OTHER PROVISIONS WITHIN
THE BILL WILL ADVANCE THE HUMAN
RIGHT TO WATER CURRENTLY ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER
WHEN THEY OPEN THE TAP. WE
CANNOT LET THIS PROCESS THAN THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES BEHIND WHEN
ADDRESSING WATER POLICY ISSUES
NOW THE STATE WATER BOARD WAS
CREATED IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
YET TO THE BEST OF OUR KNOWLEDGE
OF GOVERNANCE AND WAS THE FIRST
GOVERNOR TO APPOINT FIVE
REPRESENT IT TO THE BOARD WITH
AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
BACKGROUND. THIS THAT NUMBER WAS
LARA FIRES ON THE COMMITTEE
WATER CENTERS CO FOUNDER AND WAS
APPOINTED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THIS MEANS THAT AFTER FIFTY TWO
YEARS THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITY FINALLY HAD A DECISION
MAKER WITH THE PROVEN BACKGROUND
FOR ADVOCATING FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE- AB TWENTY ONE ZERO
TWENTY ONE ZERO EIGHT WILL
ENSURE THAT FORMER
REPRESENTATION REMAINS. AND WILL
PROVIDE MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
WITH A SEAT AT THE TABLE- SINCE
THEY ARE THE MOST IMPACTED BY
THE DECISIONS MADE AT THE WATER
BOARD IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT AB TWENTY ONE ZERO
EIGHT WILL NOT REPLACE OR CHANGE
THE CURRENT EXISTING OUR WATER
WHAT SEATS AND THAT THE BILL'S
LANGUAGE IS ACTUALLY IDENTICAL
TO EXISTING LANGUAGE. RELATING
TO A QUALIFIED REPRESENTATIVE
FROM AGRICULTURAL INTEREST IF
AGRICULTURAL INTERESTS CAN HAVE
A GUARANTEED REPRESENTATION AT
THE WATERBOARDING THEIR KEY
DECISIONS WHY CAN'T THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY WATER POLLUTION HAVE
EQUAL REPRESENTATION FOR THESE
REASONS. WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
COMMITTEE MAIN SHOW BUFFALO ON
THE DRUG FOR HEALTH BECAUSE HE
PLANTS WERE ALSO THIS THE BILL'S
HAPPY TO ANY TECHNICAL ARE YOU
MIGHT HAVE- I WANTED TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS- IN THE
ANALYSIS UP BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING REALLY CLOSELY WITH SOME
OF THE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
FOLKS- TO TIGHTEN UP THE
LANGUAGE AND DRESS THEIR
CONCERNS I REALLY DO APPRECIATE-
THOSE PARTIES HAD BEEN VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE VERY HELPFUL AND WE
FEEL LIKE WE'RE GETTING THERE
AND WE'RE JUST ABOUT THERE- ON
THE MINUTES TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS BUT- JUST A DRILL INTO
THAT LITTLE BIT- THE CONCERNS
MOSTLY COME FROM SECTIONS THREE
AND FOUR OF THE BILL. SECTION
THREE IS ABOUT THE PERMIT
ANALYSIS PIECE OF IT AND
CONCERNS FROM THE OPPOSITION
WERE THAT THE LANGUAGE SEEMS A
LITTLE LOOSE A LITTLE MORE LIKE
SEQUEL ANALYSIS THAN WHAT THE
WATER BOARDS DO A LITTLE MORE
LAND USE PLANNING SO WE'VE
REALLY BEEN DRILLING INTO THAT
SECTION TO SEE HOW THAT WOULD
WORK IN PRACTICE AT THE WATER
BOARD WE'RE ALSO REALLY WORKING
TO TIGHTEN UP THE LANGUAGE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS ISN'T GOING
TO OPEN UP- ANY ADDITIONAL
LITIGATION AND IN FACT WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT A PROVISION
THAT WOULD- MAKE SURE THAT THIS
WOULD CREATE ANY NEW CAUSES OF
ACTION- THIRD PARTY GROUPS-
PROTECTION FOR. THE ISSUES
LARGELY THE COST- AND ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT'S BEEN COMING UP
NOT JUST IN THIS BILL BUT IN ALL
LEGISLATIVE CONTEXT IS THE IDEA
OF YOU KNOW WHEN WE RUN A BILL
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE BECAUSE
OF PROBES AND YOU KNOW THEY LOOK
AT DOING IT THE GENERAL FUNDS
AND THEN GETS THE STATE WATER
BOARD- THE PROPERTIES ARE LEFT
ON THE HOOK TO ACTUALLY END UP
PAYING FOR THAT PROGRAM AND SO
WE ARE VERY SOME. CONCERN FROM
PERMITTING. MORE WORK ON
LANGUAGE THEM NOW ADDRESS. WE
FEEL LIKE SECTION FOR- A JUST AS
A BROADER. ISSUE NOT JUST A
PERMIT THE SPECIFIC ISSUE AND
THAT IT SHOULD COME OUT THE
GENERAL FUND RATHER THAN BY
PROPERTIES AND SO. WE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO FIX THOSE- AND
ADDRESS THOSE SSUES AND- WE
WERE. WERE CONTENT WE CAN GET
THERE SO. I WITHOUT I ANSWER I
DON'T THINK YOU. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANY ONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
IN SUPPORT. REFER TO NOTE THAT
WATER QUITE. BURKE SAN DIEGO
BECAUSE KEEP ELLIE WATERKEEPER
CLEAN WHAT ACTION AND LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR IN THE AND THANK.
THANK YOU. AND THE CAUSE FOR
SOME HALF THE NATURE AND INTO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OPERATOR TO
THE PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE AWAIT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN THERE ARE FAIR IN
SUPPORT. SEN AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. AT THE ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE'VE
JOINED IN SUPPORT LATE LAST
NIGHT AREN'T AFFECTED ME NOW BUT
BOTH YOU AND YOUR SUPPORT GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FORTY EIGHT. OUT
WE RUN THE ABSENT BATTLE DEFENSE
TRANSPORT. THANK YOU THANKS OVER
THE LINE THIRD FIVE YEAR LIGHTED
OPEN. NINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND LIE OF SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MORNING THIS IS ERIN WILLIAM
TO STARE CAL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU EXICO TO LINE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
IS THAT ME. YES YES- SORRY NO
ONE TOLD ME THAT I TOLD ME- HI
THIS IS REGINA CHICKEN BOLA FROM
STATE CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AND I
AM ALSO SPEAKING FOR RESTORE THE
DELTA I BELIEVE AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL MOVE BACK
TO THE ROOM FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. MORNING
START ALLEY TROUBLE WATER
ORGANIZER FOR SAVE CALIFORNIA
SALMON THAT CAN IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE OH WAIT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. DANIELLE FRANKEL SAYS
CALIFORNIA'S SALMON AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF. AB TWENTY ONE OH
EIGHT THANK YOU. LISA GOLLY
OPERATIONS MANAGER WITH
RESTORING JUSTICE FOR INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
ONE OH EIGHT THANK YOU- YEAH WE
APRIL MIGUEL A MEMBER AROUND
VALLEY NIAN TRIBES AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY ONE OH WAIT.
THANK YOU. HEY WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO- OPPOSITION WITNESSES WHICH
WE HAVE TO. HE YES IT.
KIRKHAM MADAM CHAIR DON KEPT
MCCUE KEPT ASSESS ON BEHALF THE
COW COUNTS FOR ECONOMIC AND A
THAT OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THAT WE
DO HAVE AN UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON AB ONE OH EIGHT. I
WAS NOTED BY THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR HAVE A THE ONGOING
DIALOGUE AT TO TRY TO GET TO A
WORKABLE PLACE CENTER DRESSED
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT STEVEN
IT'S MEMBERS HAVE A WHIE ON A
PRINCIPLED LEVEL OF WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THAT YOU ARE WATER
BOARDS AND ADMINISTRATIONS YOU
ALREADY HAVE THE AUTHORITY UNDER
CURRENT WATER CODE TO APPOINT
TRIBAL ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
REPRESENTATIVES TO THE WATER
BOARDS- WE DO APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH OF THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS
ON SOME ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE AND
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS ARE TO HELP
ENSURE THAT A MINIMUM. OF THAT
TO A QUORUM ISSUES ARE NOT
CONCERNED ON IN TRYING TO SEEK
INDIVIDUALS TO FILL THOSE
POSITIONS FOR THE WATER BOARD'S
CERTAINLY SOME PROGRESS ON THAT
PARTICULAR POINT ADDITIONALLY I
WE ALSO APPRECIATE OF THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS WORKING WITH THAT
ON CONCERNS RELATED OUT TO SOME
OF THE MEDICATION COMPONENTS AND
HELPING TO ADDRESS THOSE ARE
WORKING ON THAT SOME CHANGES ARE
TO HELP ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT
ARE PERHAPS OUT COULD IMPACT
SOME OF THE PERMITS ARE THAT ARE
RECEIVED MEMBERS I WORK WITH THE
WATER PORTS ON. AND DO BELIEVE
WE ARE GOING TO GET TO A
WORKABLE PLACE HERE AT VERY SOON
SO WITHOUT APPRECIATE- AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS WORKING WITH US AND
HAPPY. I TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. GOOD MORE MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
BRENDA BASS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA. CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND- AS WAS STATED WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
ONE OH EIGHT UNLESS AMENDED-
I'M- HERE AGAIN AS NOTED WE'VE
BEEN WORKING REALLY CLOSELY WITH
OF THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR ON
THIS BILL. IN AN EFFORT TO TRY
TO RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY- BUT WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS
IT'S CURRENTLY WRITTEN- AND SO.
THOSE ARE REALLY LIMITED TO
SECTIONS THREE AND FOUR OF THE
BALLOT HAS FOR EXPERTS AS WAS
EXPLAINED EARLIER- WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL ON HAS
WRITTEN IT IMPOSES NEW ANALYSIS
AND MITIGATION REQUIREMENTS
RELATED. TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY IMPACTS IN THE
PLANNING AND- PERMITTING PROCESS
HE'S BEFORE THE WATER BOARD. AND
SO BASICALLY WHAT SECTION THREE
WOULD DO CURRENTLY IS THAT IT
WOULD REQUIRE THE WATER BOARDS
TO CONSIDER AND MITIGATE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IMPACTS.
EARLY IN THE WATER ANDWATER
PROJECT PLANNING PROCESS SEES
WHICH- THE LANGUAGE IS CURRENTLY
UNCLEAR ON WORKING ON THIS.
EXTRA WHICH PROJECTS THAT WOULD
APPLY TO- THERE'S A CONCERN THAT
WOULD CREATE OVERLAP WITH SYKORA
IN TERMS OF THE TYPES OF
ANALYSIS AND MITIGATION THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED- AND- THEN AS
WE ALL KNOW WHAT SEQUENCE
SOMETIMES. ARE LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS WITH PROJECT AWAY-
SECTION FOR CREATES SEVERAL NEW
POSITIONS WITHIN THE WATER
BOARDS AND SEVERAL NEW PROGRAMS.
AND AGAIN CURRENTLY IT'S UNCLEAR
HOW THIS WILL BE FUNDED- AND
PRESENTS THE RISK THAT PERMIT
FEES WOULD BE INCREASED TO COVER
THIS NEW PROGRAM BUT- AGAIN AS
WE'VE BEEN. TALKING ABOUT HERE
WE'VE BEEN REALLY WORKING ON
TRYING TO CLEAR UP THESE TO-
CONCERNS AND I THINK WE'VE BEEN
WORKING REALLY PRODUCTIVELY. AND
I DEFINITELY LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THESE DISCUSSIONS.
WITH THE OFFER OF A SPONSOR.
BEING YOU. SIR ANY I'M UP. IN
THE ROOM. TO BETTER MY SHARE OF
MY MONICA BE HAPPY HEALTHY THE
BILL AND TO TRADES COUNCIL WE
ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
HIS STAFF ON A MINOR AMENDMENT.
THAT DOESN'T DISTURB THE INTENT
OR THE CORE OF THE OF THE BILL
IN FRONT OF YOU SO WE
APPRECIATE. SUPPORT OF THAT AND
WE'RE REALLY CLOSE TO GETTING
THIS AMENDMENT TAKEN CARE OF
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BABRI BY THE THREE
GOVERNOR ELECTIONS ON BEHALF OF
VALUE ADD WATER COALITION OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OPERATOR WE WILL MOVE TO
THE PHONES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
. YOU'RE FREE IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY ONE OH WAIT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND IS THERE A FEAR
IN OPPOSITION. WE WILL GO TO
LINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING BRITAIN SCALE DELLA
HANSLICK WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING REBEKAH BACK AND ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA COTTON
JENNER'S AND GROWERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA RIGHT
COMMISSION CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL AND A HOST OF OTHER AG
ORGANIZATION BUT NOT. AND LOCK
THEM IN A POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FOR UP ITS TO. THANK
YOU. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. MR WARD THANK YOU
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- I THINK
IT IS- IN CENTRAL THAT WE ENSURE
THAT REPRESENTATION AS A PART OF
BUT THESE BOARDS AT THE STATE
AND REGIONAL LEVEL- AND TO THE
ISSUES THAT- ARE. BEING WORKED
OUT- YOU KNOW AGREE THAT WE
SHOULD BE PRIORITIZING
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE CONCERNS
SOME OF THESE PROCEEDINGS BUT
THERE IS SOMETHING WORTHY HERE
TO REALLY DIG INTO ON THE
DETAILS THAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO GET RIGHT AS WELL- TO MAKE
SURE THERE'S NO DUPLICATION WAS
HE CLUTCHES FOR. YOUR PROCESSING
TIME AND FOR THE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE- WE DON'T WANT TO ADD
TO THAT BURDEN AS WELL SOUNDS-
WONDERFUL THAT YOU ARE WORKING
ON THOSE AS WELL AND I BELIEVE
THERE'S A PATHWAY FOR HERE FOR
ALL THE SOLUTIONS. A HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL MADAM CHAIR AND-
WILL LOOK TOWARDS SUPPORTING IT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THE WORK I WANT TO THANK.
THE OPPOSITION FOR COMING IN
WITH AN OPEN MIND TO GET TO
GUESS AND FINDING A COMMON
GROUND. WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
PROGRESS WITH WITH THE OUR WATER
ACTS OUT THERE BUT COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND
CONTINUE TO BE LEFT BEHIND INTO
LAW THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
PART OF THAT PROCESS IS ENSURING
WE HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE AND
ARE ABLE TO GUIDE THAT DECISION
MAKING IN A WAY THAT'S EQUITABLE
FOR FAR COMMUNITIES ARE MOURNS
MARGINALIZED MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES OUT THERE. A LIVE-
MY DISTRICT IS WHICH BETWEEN THE
SAME GABLE RIVERBED AND THE L.
A. RIVER BED AND WHEN I SAY THAT
I ME TELL YOU THAT IT'S TO THE
POINT TO CONCRETE WITH A LOT OF
TOXICS. OUT THERE IT'S NOT A
IT'S AT THE RIVER THAT'S BEEN
PAVED OVER OUT THERE AND IT IS
ONE OF OUR ONLY LAST OPEN SPACES
OUT THERE AND SO- THE WORK THAT
MYSTERY THIS IS BEEN DOING WITH
THIS PACKAGE OF LEGISLATION IS
HOPEFULLY GOING TO ENSURE THAT
WHEN THEY THAT REVERSIBILITY IN
SPACE. THAT'S SAFE FOR US TO USE
AND SO HOT THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK AND I THINK YOU. TO
EVERYONE FOR FINDING THE COMMON
GROUND. IT'S SO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- THIS RIVAS JUST A SOME OF
THE COM MADE BY THE AND YOUR
PLAN OF ON THROUGH SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES PLEASE. SURE IN SOLVER TO
MISTER BOFFO. A OF YOU KNOW. THE
TECHO OUT THE TECH TO ASPECTS OF
- THE BILL I WOULD CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW- WE'VE- WE'VE ENGAGED THE
OPPOSITION CERTAINLY AS YOU OVER
SOME OF THE COMMENTS ARE MADE BY
SOME NUMBER WARD. WE WANNA GET
THIS RIGHT NOW BUT AT THE END IT
YET YOU KNOW THE SAME TIME WE
KNOW THAT APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE BY THE WATER
AGENCIES TO. YOU KNOW- DO A
BETTER JOB IN- ADDRESSING THESE
LONG STANDING ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE CONCERNS- BUT CERTAINLY-
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE- AND SO
CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW THAT'S- OUR
GOAL BUT AT SAME TIME UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERNS ARE VERY REAL
CONCERNS AND WE WANT TO. ENSURE
THAT THAT- WE'RE ADDRESSING
pAMENDMENTS TO FOR THAT WE GET IT
RIGHT WITH POWER. THANK YOU. SO
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD- THE
SPECIFIC AREA YOU WANT ME TO
DRILL IN ON- BUTTON JUST REAL
FAST THERE'S THIS THE TWO
SECTIONS ON STATE AND REGIONAL
BOARD- APPOINTMENTS- WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON LANGUAGE ONE TO
ASSURE THAT THE AGRICULTURAL
SEAT ISN'T THE SAME AS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE SEE AND
THIS IS WORKING WITH FARM BUREAU
AND ALL THE FOLKS TO MAKE SURE
THAT'S WHAT YOU KNOW I THINK WE
ALL AGREE THAT THAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE TO TAKE AND
THEN AS MISS CAP HE SAID WERE
ALSO WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE EGR TRIBALS HE DOESN'T HOLD
UP A QUORUM OF PARTICULAR FOR
REGIONAL BOARDS AND THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO US AS WELL
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE BOARD
WITHOUT QUORUMS AND SO WE'RE
DEFINITELY GOING TO BE EXPLORING
THAT AND MAKING SURE YOU HAVE A
MINUTE THERE I'M ON THE ISSUE
ABOUT THE SEQUEL STOP REAL QUICK
TO DRILL N ON WHAT WE'RE VISION
WHAT THE INTENT WAS- THERE
THERE'S ESSENTIALLY GOING TO BE
TWO SECTIONS ONE SECTION ISGONNA BE SPUR STATEWIDE AND
REGIONAL PERMITS AND THE IDEA IS
REALLY JUST AROUND TRANSPARENCY
AND SO THE WAY WE ENVISION IT
IS. A SIMPLE PARAGRAPH OR TWO IN
IN IN THEIR STAFF REPORT WHAT WE
WANT THAT PARAGRAPH TO DO IS ONE
IDENTIFY THE TRADE OFFS IN THE
APARTMENT OR POLICY SO FOR
EXAMPLE MAYBE WE'RE NOT
REQUIRING MONITORING EVERYWHERE
BUT THAT'S BECAUSE WE WANT
PEOPLE TO PUT MORE ENERGY INTO
ACTUALLY IMPROVING THE WATER
QUALITY RIGHT THERE'S TRADE
OFFS- SO IDENTIFY THOSE TRADE
OFFS AND THEN IDENTIFY WAYS TO
REDUCE THE IMPACT THOSE TRADE
OFFS HAVE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE OR TRIBAL COMMUNITIES.
BOB IT DOESN'T REQUIRE ANY OF
THOSE TO NECESSARILY- HE PUT
INTO THE PERMANENT POLICY BUT WE
WANT TO CISION MAKERS TO KNOW
HOW THEY CAN REDUCE THOSE
IMPACTS AND THEN SIMILARLY FOR
INDIVIDUAL PERMITS LOCAL PERMITS
WE THERE'S A LOT OUT THERE WE
DON'T WANT EVERY PERMIT TO HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THIS ANALYSIS TO
WEAR TRIMMING IT DOWN. NARROWING
IT DOWN TO JUST THOSE INDIVIDUAL
PERMITS ARE GETTING SOME TYPE OF
EXEMPTION A TIME SCHEDULE ORDER
THAT EXTENDS OUT THE COMPLIANCE
DATE A WATER QUALITYVARIANTS
THAT CHANGES THE STANDARD FOR
PERMITTING ONLY THOSE FOLKS
WOULD GET THIS ANALYSIS AND THE
WAY WE ENVISION IS IT WOULD BE A
FINDING AND THE FINDING WOULD
AGAIN SAY WHAT THE TRADE OFF IS
THE TIME SCHEDULE EXTENSION AND
THEN SAY THIS MAY. IMPACT ON THE
COULD. THE COMMUNITY THAT'S IT'S
BEEN DO. INTO AGAIN NOTHING'S
BEING REQUIRED FOR. JUST AT THE-
FINDINGS BE THEY- SO THAT THE
DECISION. KNOWS WHAT TRY OFFS
ARE BE MADE BY. THAT'S THE KEY
AND SO WE'RE TAKING OUT ANYTHING
THAT LOOKED LAND YOU SEE WILL
LIKE IT'S JUST WHAT THE WATER
BOARD'S AUTHORITIES ABOUT- AND
THEN LASTLY I.
ALREADY WENT OVER THE LIMIT BUT
ON THE COST. PART OF IT- AGAIN
WE'RE TRYING TO. PUT SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE IN THAT SAYS WE'RE NOT
RAISING PERMITS FEES. AND THEN
THERE'S A PROVISION IN THERE
ABOUT A HARDSHIP STIPEND- WE
HAVE TO HAVE ANOTHER-
LEGISLATION TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN.
THAT LOOKS AT TAKING MONEY FROM.
OTHER STATE WATER BOARDS
ENFORCEMENT. FUND TO HELP FUND-
THAT HARDSHIP FUND FOR THIRD
PARTIES TO BE ABLE TO. LANGUAGE
ACCESS BARRIER ISSUES- NOT HAVE
COMPUTER ACCESS OR WIFI ACCESS
WHATEVER THE BARRIER IS FOR THAT
COMMUNITY IT'S NOT BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN REGULATORY
PROCESS. THAT FUNDING WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO HELP THEM SO THAT
THEY COULD BE. AVAILABLE SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE KEY. MOST ASK
THANK YOU THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT FURTHER EXPLANATION. ANY
OTHER MEMBERS. QUESTION THIS
REGULAR. IF THE REST OF THE
ISSUE IS REALLY MORE ABOUT
WANTING TO MAKE SURE CERTAIN
TERMS AND CONDITIONS ARE MET OUR
FINDINGS ARE MET WHY THE EXTRA
ADDED COMPONENTS WHY HAVE THE
EXTRA SEATS AT THE TABLE IF YOU
REALLY JUST WANT THOSE ISSUES.
ADDRESSED WHAT DO YOU NEED THE
EXTRA. WELL I. MEAN I THINK THE
HEART OF THE BILL IS THE
REPRESENTATION- AT YOU KNOW AT
THIS IS WE'VE SPOKEN ABOUT THERE
HAS BEEN A LACK OF
REPRESENTATION ON THESE BOARDS
IN THE PAST WE FEEL IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED BY THESE
WATER BODIES ASIANS DO HAVE
REPRESENTATION THERE SO I THINK
THAT'S- THE KEY IN THE HEART OF
THE BILL- THE PERMANENT NOW WITH
THE SECTION IS. SOMEWHAT
SEPARATE- BUT REALLY THE INTENT
THERE IS AGAIN JUST TO HAVE THE
DECISION MAKERS KNOW WHAT THE
MAKING A DECISION ON WHAT ARE
THE TRADEOFFS WHAT ARE THE
IMPACTS TO THE COMMUNITY AND
THEN THEY CAN AUTHORIZE THAT
NOTHING'S PREVENTING THEM FROM
NOT AUTHORIZING IT WE JUST WANT
THEM TO KNOW. WHAT THEY'RE
AUTHORIZES. OKAY. FRIEDMAN SURE
I SOMEONE WHO SAT ON A WATER
BOARD FOR SEVEN YEARS I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD THAT REPRESENTATION
IS KEY AND THESE DECISIONS-
INVOLVING WATER ARE HUGE AND
HUGELY HUGELY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE'S QUALITY OF LIFE AND
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT THE
COMMUNITIES NOT ONLY HAVE A
VOICE BUT HAVE SOMEONE WHO CAN
ACT AS THAT BRIDGE TO GO BACK TO
THEM AND EXPLAIN TO THEM WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND WHY AND THAT OFTEN
IS LACKING IS THE REASON I WENT
ON THE WATER BOARD OF FOR ME AND
MY COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
HAVE ANYONE WHO IS ROUTINELY
UPDATING THE PUBLIC. ABOUT THOSE
VERY IMPACTFUL DECISIONS SO I
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL
AND I'M- VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY. A MEASURE NUMBER
NUMBER ONE- I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR COMING FORWARD WITH THIS-
AND- I'D LIKE TO BE LISTED AS A
CO SPONSOR- AS IT MOVES FORWARD-
TO WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS- I SERVED ON
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY I HAD. A LOT OF
INTERACTIONS WITH THE- ARE
ROUGH. WATER BOARD DEBT DOWN THE
LOS ANGELES AREA CENTER. AND I'M
NOT ARE ALL WORRIED ABOUT- THIS
ONE REPRESENTATIVE- SOMEHOW
OVERWHELMING THE DIRECTION THAT.
THERE IS CERTAINLY VERY STRONG
REPRESENTATION BY- ALL THE WATER
INTEREST- AND- SO I THINK THIS
TO SUGGEST AS A HEALTHY. AND
APPROPRIATE- BALANCING- THAT- IT
RECOGNIZES TOO MANY TIMES WE
SIMPLY OVERLOOKED TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES- THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THREE OF US WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THE QUESTIONS IN THE
DISCUSSION AND RESPECT FAST WHEN
I. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
WE DON'T HAVE A SECOND THANK.
THANK YOU. CALDERON THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROACH DOLLY
DALI NOT VOTING NAZARIAN SENATE
BENNETT I BIGELOW BIGELOW NOW
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA
GARCIA I KALRA LEVINE MURATSUCHI
NO ONE. RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS I SMITH. SMITH NOVIA PUTRA
WARD WARD I. THANK YOU. MISTER
BLOOM.
GOOD MORNING MADAM VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN
WHICH REQUIRES THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO ESTABLISH A WATER LAW
TRAINING AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS
FOR JUDGES AND ALLOW THE CHIEF
JUSTICE TO ASSIGN COMPLEX WATER
CASES TO TRAIN JUDGES IT WOULD
ALSO PROVIDE JUDGES WITH EXPERT
RESOURCES DEVELOPED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO ASSESS TRIAL
JUDGES IN ADJUDICATING THESE
COMPLEX CASES. I'D LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE BILL
. AS CALIFORNIA SUFFERS YET
ANOTHER RECORD BREAKING DROUGHT
CONFLICTS OVER WATER HAVE
INCREASED AND THE LITIGATION
RESULTING FROM THESE CONFLICTS.
IS FREQUENTLY OF A COMPLEX
NATURE REQUIRING EXPERTISE AND
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TO RESOLVE
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN OFFERS
A DYNAMIC. APPROACH TO DELIVER
THE CRITICALLY NEEDED TRAINING
AND RESOURCES TO ASSIST JUDGES
ACROSS THE STATE IN RESOLVING
THESE CONFLICTS. EFFECTIVELY I
AM PLEASED TO BE JOINED BY RYAN
DESERVE A SHAREHOLDER IN THE LAW
FIRM OF BARKER WHAT'S CHRONIC
AND SHANAHAN IN SACRAMENTO.
WHOSE PRACTICE WATER LAW IN MANY
PARTS OF THE STATE FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS. WILL BE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU. KITCO HAVE
MISPERCEPTIONS I'M THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YES LIVE- PRACTICE
WATER LAWS VARIETY VARIES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
AND WHAT YOU SEE IN MANY OF
THESE WATER CASES. IS
ESSENTIALLY THREE CROSSCUTTING
COMPLEXITIES THAT MAKE THEM VERY
DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH WITHIN
THE OURTS. ON THE FIRST IS THAT
THEY TEND TO HAVE MANY MANY
PARTIES. AND SOMETIMES THEY'RE
IN MULTIPLE COUNTIES AND SO YOU
HAVE LAWSUITS GET FILED IN
MULTIPLE COUNTY SOMETIMES
SOMETIMES WITH HUNDREDS OF
PARTIES. THE SECOND IS THAT THEY
TEND TO BE EXTREMELY TECHNICAL
SO YOU HAVE A- GREAT DEAL OF
EXPERTISE- TESTIMONY AND MANY OF
THE CASES AND EVEN IN THE CASES
COMING OUT OF THE WATER BOARD-
WHERE YOU HAVE AN ADMINISTRATIVE
RECORD THE ISSUES TEND TO BE
QUITE TECHNICAL. AND THEN- THIRD
THEY TEND TO BE VERY DOCUMENT
HEAVY EVEN IF IT EVEN IF IT IS A
WATER BOARD MATTER WITHIN
ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD- THE
RECORD TENDS TO BE VERY LARGE.
AND SO YOU YOU HAVE A VERY
COMPLEX MANAGEMENT PROBLEM FOR
THE COURTS AND- HAVING AND- A
TRAINING PROGRAM FOR THE JUDGES
AND THE POTENTIAL SILENCE TO THE
TRAINING JUDGES I THINK WE MAKE
A LOT OF SENSE IN HELPING THESE
CASES. WHICH CAN AFFECT THE
ENTIRE REGIONS- MOVE. FORWARD
EFFECTIVELY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SIR ANY OTHER WAY. AND SOME
IN THE ROOM TODAY. GOOD MORNING
KYLE JONES WITH COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
CLEAN WATER ACTION WE APOLOGIZE
FOR NOT GETTING A LETTER
IMMIGRANTS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR PLEASE REFER
TO THE PHONES AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS THE ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR IN SUPPORT.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES CHRIS
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WITH THE SUPPORT OF
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ANTHONY MILLION ON
BEHALF OF SANTA CLARITA VALLEY
WATER AGENCIES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
LINE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE UNDER
AVERAGE OUT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
WITH THE POOR AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEDICARE WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORTING Q. THANK YOU
TO HAVE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. PROPERTY COMMITTED TO THE
PHONES IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
FOR IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
MANAGER THANK YOU MOVING BACK TO
THE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMON K. IT'S REALLY TAKES
CLOSE THANK YOU AGAIN THAT- THE
SENATE BILL IS AT ITS CORE A
GOOD GOVERNMENT MEASURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I PUT. WE
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AT MENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
DOLLY HI DALY AYE NAZARIAN.
BENNETT BENNETT I BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I
GARCIA GARCIA I. KALRA KALRA
I'LL LEVINE MURATSUCHI NO WHEN
RUBIO. I'D BE APPROVED BY THE
VALLAPUDUA I WARD WARD I. LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR MEMBERS THAT ON
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YEAH.
WITNESSES THAT AS WITH. ON THE
PHONE NORTHERN PERSON THANK YOU
YEAH FOR THE MOST. YEAH SECOND.
VERY THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS- AB
TWENTY FOUR TWELVE WILL CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA SMALL
FARMERS SAVE WATER AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
CURRENTLY THE SUSTAINABLE WATER
EFFICIENCY ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM
SWEEP CURRENTLY PROP UP POTTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE HAS HELPED
HUNDREDS OF FARMERS SAVE A
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN THOUSAND ACRE
FEET OF WATER AND REDUCES EIGHTY
ONE THOUSAND METRIC TONS OF CO
TWO ACROSS A HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND ACRES FURTHER WATER
SAVINGS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS CAN BE GAINED. BY
DIRECTING RUNOFF FROM WATER
ACCESS RUNOFF IRRIGATION CAN BE
USED TO IRRIGATE CROPS RECHARGE
GROUNDWATER OR BE TRANSFERRED TO
OTHER USERS DOWNSTREAM WHILE
REDUCING CO TWO AB TWENTY FOUR
TWELVE EXTENSIVE SUITE PROGRAM
TO SUPPORT SMALL FARMERS. ED RE
DIRECTING AND STORING IRRIGATION
RUNOFF WITH ME TODAY IS- TAYLOR
ROSHEN POLICY ADVISER AS THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION. AND CONRAD MATHIS.
BURGER ERROR NANAMI ADVISER FOR
SOIL AND GREEN AT THE UNIVERSITY
TO CALIFORNIA- CORPORATE
EXTENSION CAPITAL- QUARTER. WITH
ME THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS DELIVER SOME OF
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU I
WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR TWELVE AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF THE AUTHOR AND STAFF-
FOR MOVING THE MEASURE FORWARD-
AS YOU ON THE SWEEPS A VERY
POPULAR VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
IN IMPLEMENTING WATER EFFICIENCY
ON FARMS AT ACROSS THE STATE-
AND IT'S REALLY HELPING OUR
FARMING MEMBERS ADAPT TO CLIMATE
CHANGE DROUGHT IMPACTS- AND
PURSUE WATER AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY THROUGH THE
IRRIGATION SYSTEMS- I WANT NOTED
THAT BEYOND ITS SUBSCRIPTION
RATE IT'S OVERSUBSCRIBED EVERY
YEAR SINCE IT'S- BEEN
ESTABLISHED BY THE LEGISLATURE-
IT'S ONE OF THE ONLY FARMER
FACING PROGRAM REALLY ELIGIBLE
DIRECTLY TO FARMERS TO MAKE THIS
YOUR CATION EFFICIENCY
IMPROVEMENTS AND REALLY PROUD
HOW IT CAN MODEL HOW.
AGRICULTURE AND CONSERVATION GO
HAND IN HAND- SO THIS BILL
REALLY MODERNIZES SWEEP IT
CODIFIES AND HOPEFULLY
ENCOURAGES MORE SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING FOR SWEET MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. IN. THAT.
YES YEAH RIGHT- SO I GOT LIKE
I'D LIKE TO MOVE MAYBE YES-
LET'S TRYING TO PUT MYSELF ON OF
IT IS AT A GENERAL I- OKAY SO MY
NAME IS CONNOR UNDERGROUND
ADVISOR WITH UNIVERSITY CAL CAR
EXTENT THAT'S A WERE HOUSE I AG
AND NATURAL RESOURCES SO YOU SEE
A AND R. AND YEAH I THEY THEY
JUST NEED I'M TALKING BIT ABOUT
THE PRO HERE I THINK OF THE MAIN
THAT I HAD ABOUT IT WHEN I READ
OVER THE BILL WAS THAT IT DOES
MAKE IT A LITTLE MORE CONSISTENT
AND AS MANY OF YOU KNOW- YOU
KNOW WE ARE WE DO FACE A LOT OF.
WE FREQUENTLY FACE DROUGHTS IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK IT'S PRETTY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR GIRLS TO BE
ABLE TO BE QUICK ON THEIR FEET
AND REACT TO THAT- AND THIS FOR
YOU KNOW HAVING THIS THAT THE
FUNDING KIND OF ON A ON A
CONTINUOUS BASIS WOULD. HELP
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE THINGS
THAT. RICE FARMERS. GROWERS YOU
KNOW. GRAIN GROWERS CAN- TO.
THEM DURING IN SEASON THAT WILL
ALLOW THEM TO CONSERVE OR MOVE
WATER WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE
MOVED- AND HAVING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DO THAT WHICH
IS WHAT SWEET IS KIND OF BUILT
TO DO- IT WOULD. WOULD IMPROVE
THEIR ABILITY TO DO THEIR JOB-
AND ON TOP OF THAT YOU KNOW I
CAN SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WORKING WITH SOME OF THE
COMMUNITY EDUCATION SPECIALISTS
WHO WERE FUNDED. BY THE HEALTHY
SOILS PROGRAM. IS KIND OF A
SISTER PROGRAM. THEY'RE ALSO
THEY'RE ALSO STRUGGLING WITH THE
FACT THAT. THEY BE TALKING TO
FARMERS AND LOSING INTEREST IN
FARMERS NOT WANTED
UNNECESSARILY. SET UP
APPLICATIONS GET EVERYTHING
READY FOR THE NEXT CYCLE BECAUSE
THEY WEREN'T SURE IF IT WAS
GOING TO GET FUNDED AGAIN- SO
IT'S KIND A LOT OF. WASTED
EFFORT. IN PEACE. WITH PEOPLE
WHO ARE WILLING TO DO THIS- THAT
I THINK IT'S JUST AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT. YOU KNOW GIVEN THE FACT
THAT WE ARE NOW IN. THAT WE ALL
KIND OF ACCEPT THAT WE'RE
DROUGHT CONDITIONS. AS LIKE A-
PERMANENT FIXTURE. AND GOES AND
FRANKLY FROM A CROP PERSPECTIVE.
WE HAVE DROUGHT CONDITIONS THAT.
THAT EXIST WITHIN A SEASON. SO
THIS YEAR WE HAD TWO MAJOR
DOWNFALL- DOWNPOURS AND IN
BETWEEN THAT IT WAS NOTHING. AND
SO THEIR STRESS INVOLVED AND
HAVING MORE INFRASTRUCTURE
ALLOWS FOR CROSS CONFLICTS WITH
THAT. I THINK IT'S JUST A
VALUABLE TOOL FOR THEM HAVING A
TOOL BELT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. THIRTY IN AN MORE SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM- NO WHICH
MIGHT BE FOLKS ON THE TELEPHONE
ON TO THE- IN SUPPORT. OF BERMAN
SURE MEMBERS- TROLLS STILL GONNA
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR SUSTAINABLE
CONSERVATION- WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORT OF PROGRAMS LIKE SWEET
TO PROVIDE INCENTIVES FOR
SUSTAINABLE PRACTICE MY PHARMACY
AND WAS TRANSPORTED AB OR PAUL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
ROOM. OPERATOR PLEASE MOVE TO
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
TWELVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND
THEN THEY'RE ALL FAIR IN SUPPORT
. AND WE ILL GO TO LINE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE NUMBER THIS IS
BRIAN SHOW BUT THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK.
HOW CAN HAVE BEEN A SUPPORT
AMENDED PETITION AND WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
WORKING WITH US ON A COUPLE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENT BILL. THANK. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
ONLINE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS GAIL
DEL HANDS WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE MONEY BILL
WOULD YOU KNOW RELEGATION AND
PARKLIFE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR TWELVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU SIR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. OPERATOR
PLEASE MOVE TO PHONES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
TWELVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND
THEN THEY'RE OFF HERE IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO
LIVE IN SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS DENNIS I'LL
BE ON THE BEHALF OF THE-
CALIFORNIA GREEN ISSUES SUCH AS
SHE CALIFORNIA SHE DISSERTATION
OF ANY OTHER AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS WE SUPPORT. WE ARE
IN SUPPORT. THANK THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THANK
YOU WOULD YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SPEAK WE ASPEN AYE BUT
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS DOLLY HI DALY AYE
NAZARIAN. BENNETT BENNETT I
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA I
KALRA. KALRA I. LEVINE SUU KYI
WHEN RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS
AYE AYES SMITH SMITH IV APPROVAL
BY THE VALLAPUDUA AYE WARD WARD
I. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU. MISTER
SEA ICE.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING KIND
OF CHAIRED COLLEAGUES- YEAH I
PRESENT TO YOU AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE THE BILL WOULD SERVE
AS A MECHANISM FOR STATE PARKS
TO ENSURE. THAT ALL APPLICANTS
RECEIVING FUNDING FROM THE STATE
PROVIDE FULL ACCESS TO ALL TYPES
OF DISABILITIES- AND BOTH THE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL AS IT
RELATES TO ACCESS TO OUR PARKS
AND SOLD STRICTLY AS CREATE VOTE
HAVE VERY KARIS WITH ME WHO WILL
TESTIFY. ABOUT THE- BUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE ISSUE. THE
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS ERIC
HARRIS I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY AT DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA- WE ARE HERE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY FIVE A BILL THAT
WOULD GRANT. THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT ANY GRANT FOR UP FOR- PARKS
WORD- HAVE TO HAVE ACCESSIBLE
PARKS- DISABLED PEOPLE LIKE
MYSELF ESPECIALLY DISABLED
CHILDREN DESERVE TO HAVE FULL
ACCESS TO LIVE THEIR LIVES HOW
THEY CHOOSE. THIS SHOULD INCLUDE
BEING ABLE TO ENJOY ACCESSIBLE
PARKS MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS HAVE
STATED THAT PHYSICAL ACTIVITY
FOR SOME DISABLED CHILDREN CAN
BE VITAL FOR THEIR PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLBEING. IN
SOME CASES CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES MUST HAVE REGULAR
OUTDOOR ACTIVITY BECAUSE IT IS
CRUCIAL FOR THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
ACTUALLY 13% OF CHILDREN IN
SCHOOLS HAVE DISABILITIES AND
THESE CHILDREN HAVE MOBILITY
SENSORY INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
IT IS CRUCIAL THAT CALIFORNIA
CONSIDER. THESE CHILDREN AS IT
CONTINUES TO IMPROVE AND PROVIDE
FUNDING- AND IT'S DEVELOPMENT
FOR PARKS MANY PARENTS OF
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES HAVE
TO SEARCH WITHIN THEIR CITIES OR
IN THE SURROUNDING AREAS TO FIND
ACCESSIBLE PARKS FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. AFTER MANY PARKS HAVE
NOT BEEN RENOVATED IN DECADES
SOME CITIES ARE BEGINNING TO
THINK ABOUT AND WORK WITH
ORGANIZATIONS TO ADDRESS HOW
PARKS CAN BE MORE ACCESSIBLE. AS
CITIES BECOME MORE MODERN IT IS
CRUCIAL THAT OUR POLICYMAKERS
AND LEADERS URGE THEM TO BE MORE
ACCESSIBLE FOR ALL PEOPLE WITH
ALL THIS TYPES OF DISABILITIES I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY TWO QUICK
POINTS ABOUT ACCESSIBILITY.
ANYBODY CAN DEVELOP A DISABILITY
AT ANY TIME ANYONE CAN DEVELOP A
MENTAL HEALTH DISABILITY BECOME
INJURED AND AS WE KNOW AS WE AGE
WE LOSE OUR ABILITY TO HEAR OR
OR SEE CLEARLY. AND TO
ACCESSIBILITY ULTIMATELY IS GOOD
FOR EVERYONE PEOPLE WHO ARE
INJURED INCLUDING PEOPLE WHO ARE
USING AIDS TO HELP THEM MOVE
PEOPLE WHO ARE CARRYING OR WITH
YOUNG CHILDREN AND MORE DISABLED
CHILDREN DESERVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE FULL ACCESS TO PARKS AND
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE IS A
BILL THAT CAN HELP US MOVE IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION- WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU. NO
ONE ELSE IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT
. OPERATE PLEASE MOVE TO THE
PHONES IN SUPPORT. GIVE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO FAIR IN SUPPORT. THE
MANAGER WE HAVE NO SUPPORT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE ROOM ANY OPPOSITION
. OPERATOR ON THE PHONES AT ANY
OPPOSITION PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
AMEND THEIR AFFAIR IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE.
THE MANAGER WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN Q. THANK YOU
MOVING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. YES YEAH I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND JUST TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE ANECDOTAL
STORY OF I AM NOT STORY BUT-
EVIDENCE AS TO WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT FOR ALL KIDS- MY CITY
HAS BEEN INSTALLING ACCESSIBLE
PLAYGROUNDS. IN OUR PARKS AND
IT'S LED TO ME BEING ABLE TO A
VERY NATURALLY HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY DAUGHTER
ABOUT DIFFERENT ABILITIES AND OF
COURSE BEING ABLE TO PLAY WITH
DIFFERENTLY ABLED CHILDREN.
REALLY HELPS CREATE A SENSE OF
EMPATHY AND UNDERSTANDING THAT
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY WILL LAST AS
CHILDREN AS THEY MOVE FORWARD
AND THEY CAN LIVE THEIR WHILE
LIVES IN WAYS THAT WELCOMES
OTHERS SO I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF BENEFITS OF THIS. THANKS.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- WILL YOU ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT YES WE ARE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS- THANK YOU AND-
APPRECIATE YOU SHARING THAT
STORY BECAUSE THAT. THAT IS THE-
THE ESSENCE OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH HERE THE- REAL
PEOPLE WHO WILL BE IMPACTED BY
THIS POLICY. AND THANK YOU AND
RESPECT LAST RIVAL THANK YOU I'D
ALSO LIKE TO BE CONSIDERED AS A
CO AUTHOR. OF THE THANK YOU.
REFER ME TO MOTION A SECOND.
SECOND THANK YOU. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
DALI DALI I THE SYRIAN. BENNETT
BENNETT I BIGELOW BIGELOW-
COLLECTORS WHEN. BIGELOW I'D
FRIEDMAN JUMP OUT OF THE CAR.
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA S. CI KALRA
KALRA I. LEVINE MURATSUCHI WHEN
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS AYE
AYES SMITH. SMITH I BE
VALLAPUDUA BE APPROVED BY WARD
WORD I. THANK WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR MEMBERS SAT ON THE YOU. CRITICISM HAS. ON MISTER K.
AND I CAN SEE. THE PEOPLE.
THANK MADAM CHAIR CALL I AM
TODAY PERCENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FORTY WHICH WERE JUST THE
OUTSIDE PROGRAM TO PROMOTE PARK
ACCESS FOR ALL AGES EXTEND
OUTDOOR EDUCATION AND DEVELOP
CAREER PATHWAYS FOR THE OUTDOORS
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL GRANT PROGRAMS ESTABLISH
A LADY TOPPER ACCESS THAT SEEK
TO SUPPORT OUTDOOR RECREATION
WELL THESE VITALLY IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS PARTAKING YOUTH OUT OR
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES ON STATE
PARKS THEY FALL SHORT AND THEY
FALL SHORT IN PROVIDING
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES TO ADDRESS THIS
IMPORTANT NEED. AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY SIX SEEKS TO CLOSE THIS
GAP IN OUTDOOR ACCESS FUNDING BY
PROVIDING RESOURCES TO LOCAL
AGENCIES AND NONPROFITS TO
PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMMING MULTILINGUAL
TRANSLATION WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT CAREER PATHWAY
PROGRAMS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION FOR ALL EDUCATORS BY
DELIVERING FUNDING FOR THESE
SERVICES AND A BROADER RANGE OF
COMMUNITY ACCESS PROGRAMS AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX WILL HELP
TO ALLEVIATE EXISTING BARRIERS
DR ACCESS AND CONTINUE WORKING
TOWARDS THE GOAL OF MAKING THE
OUTDOORS ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY BY PHONE IS MORRIS
ALAIN'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA NEED GOV COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION AND TO TESTIFY
IN PERSON IS DEANNA THE TOR
DARKENED GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
MANAGER OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION THANK YOU AND
RIP REQUEST WE REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THIS LETTER WE YOU LIKE TO
PROCEED- I BELIEVE SOME OF. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE- AUDIBLE CHE
COMMITTEE FEAR TIME- I NAME IS
DAN LATORRE. AND I AM THE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION- THE CONFERENCE HE'S
PARKS FOUNDATION AS A SEVENTY
THOUSAND MEMBER STRONG NONPROFIT
THAT MOBILIZES A DIVERSE.
NETWORK OF CALIFORNIANS TO
PROTECT AND PRESERVE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOR ALL. I'M HAPPY
TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT AS A
MEMBER GABRIEL'S AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY SIX ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION- SUPPORTING THE
ABILITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
ACCESS- AND BUT THE BENEFITS OF
OUTDOORS HAS ALWAYS BEEN
IMPORTANT BUT OBVIOUSLY COVER
NINETEEN EMPHASIZED THIS FACT-
AS THE ANALYSIS ON PAGE THREE
WONDERFULLY OUT DEADLINES
THERE'S- A PLETHORA OF LINKS
BETWEEN THE OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES
AND THE EMOTIONAL MENTAL AND
ACADEMIC BENEFITS- HOWEVER
ACCESS THE OUTDOORS IS NOT
EQUITABLE FOR ALL. A NUMBER OF
FACTORS SERVE AS BARRIERS TO
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES INCLUDING
LACK OF TRANSPORTATION
TRANSLATION SERVICES OR EVEN
KNOWLEDGE OF WHERE AND HOW TO
ACCESS PARKS- AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY SIX ADDRESSES THESE AND
OTHER QUALITIES BY CREATING THE
CALIFORNIA'S OUTSIDE GRANT
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR ALL AGES TO- FOR
PROGRAMS THAT ENHANCE PARK
ACCESS FOR ALL AGES EXPAND
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES FOR ALL AND
DEVELOP OUTDOOR CAREER PATHWAYS.
PROGRAM WORKED IN TANDEM WITH
TWO EXISTING GRANT PROGRAMS AS A
MEMBER GABRIEL NOTED TO YOU
COMMITTEE ACCESS PROGRAM AND THE
OUTDOOR EQUITY GRANT PROGRAM-
AND WE SEE THIS PROGRAM IS
EXTENDING OUT CORRECTIVE DEED
ALL POIGNANT AND FILLING A GAP
FOR EXISTING FUNDING FOR AFTER
ACCESS PROGRAMS- SO IN CLOSING
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION BELIEVES THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS. TO PARKS AND OPEN OPEN
SPACES ESPECIALLY CALIFORNIA'S
REMARKABLE STATE PARK SO FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON A BEACH
AT TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION TODAY. THE YOU.
OPERATOR CAN WE GET MISS LANE ON
THE LINE PLEASE. I'M HERE- THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AND
I'M ABOUT SHAREFILE KM AND
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS MADDIE THANK
YOUNG HAS BEEN UNDER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PEDIATRIC COLLECTION
LOS ANGELES BASED NONPROFIT
WHOSE MISSION. UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY AND OUTSIDE OF FOR
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OUR
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN LIVE BARRIER
PLEASE CHECK MY FEEDBACK THEN
BUT I'M NOT. FINANCIAL
CALAMITIES I THE FRONT DOOR OF
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY I'M
HONORED BE HERE TODAY THAT WE
CAN THE PART OF THE FOR PLEASE.
BROUGH GRANT PROGRAMS AND
ESTABLISHED WITH THE FUNDING TO
ADDRESS BARRIERS CALDERON LIKE
THAT EQUITY GRANT PRO CREATE VIA
A TWO OH NINE BY SENATOR IYMAN
IN TWO EIGHTEEN ON THE U.
COMMUNITY CRAP ACCESS GRANT
PROGRAM IS IN FUNDED PAPA. SIXTY
FOUR. IN PROGRAMS PLAY A VITAL
OPENING. OUTDOOR I FOR CAL. AND
BE STRONG SUPPORT THEM HELLO
THERE BUT THE REASONS WHY TO
FIND ACCESS PATCH. TARGETED
TOWARDS YOU AND STUDENTS AND DO
NOT. ALL OF THE DIVERSE.
COMMUNITY ACT PROGRAM THAT ARE
GOING TO BE LIKE EACH TO GET. IN
THE TO COMMUNITY CAN BETWEEN. AB
TWENTY FORTY SIX. SUPPORT THESE.
PROGRAMS AND CHALLENGE THE
REMAINING GAPS FUNDING FOR OUT
ACCESS BAKER. OVER ARCHING.
THREE PRONGED PROGRAM AT THE RI
THAT AGENCY THAT WHAT THE SHE
WAS THE PRO. IN ADDITION TO.
OUTSIDE PROGRAM WHICH I BE A
STOP BY THIS LOGIC. BUT HOW.
OUTSIDE PROGRAM WILL WORK
ALONGSIDE EXISTING PRO AND
PROVIDES FOR ACROSS RANGE OF OUT
ACCESS PROJECT FOR ALL AGES.
WELL ALLOWING THE EXISTING PRO.
TO CONTINUE THE PERFECT
MRS IN SUPPORT. IN THE ROOM. HI
ABIGAIL MILE ON BEHALF OF THE
MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT SAID THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE AND NATURE FOR ALL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CHEN MEMBERS
READ ADDRESS ON BEHALF OF THE
STATEWIDEASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES IN STRONG
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WE MOVED TO THE PHONE LINES
AND SUPPORT PLEASE. DO YOU
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO FEAR IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX. IN ONE
MOMENT MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE TO
KEEP ANOTHER. AGAIN WE AREIN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
SIX AND WE WILL GO TO LINE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CATHY SCHAEFER ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BINOD SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN Q.
THANK YOU THE OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. OPERATOR CAN GIVE TO
OPPOSITION THE PHONE LINES
PLEASE. THANK OU OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR IN OPPOSITION. I'M SURE WE
HAVE NOOPPOSITION IN KILL THANK
YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE
MOTION. SECT THANK YOU. STRIEBER
WHICH I'D LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MANAGER WE
ARE I THINK IS EVERYONE FROM
EVERY CORNER OF THE STATE KNOWS
BUT SOME SOME EXTRAORDINARY
NATURAL RESOURCES IN THE STATE-
BUT WE'VE HAD SOME VERY
PERSISTENT EQUITY ISSUES IN
TERMS OF WHO'S ABLE TO ACCESS
THOSE RESOURCES- WE'VE MADE REAL
PROGRESS IN RECENT YEARS AS IT
COMES OUT RISK YOUTH BUT WE
THINK THAT THE PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS OF OUTDOOR ACCESS BUT
NOW TO BE EXPENDED TO EVERYBODY
AND SO WITH THAT WOULD WITH THE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATE. DOLLY I L. A. I.
NINE. BENNETT BENNETT I BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GARCIA GARCIA I KALRA
KALRA EYED LEVINE MURATSUCHI
WHEN. RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS AYE AYES SMITH SMITH FIVE
BE APPROVED FOR THE VALLAPUDUA
AYE WARD WARD I. THANK YOU WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR. MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU- MISTER. THE
STREAMS LAST YEAR. YEAH. YEAH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY FIVE TO YOU TODAY
AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY FIVE UPDATES THE
TEMPORARY WATER TRANSFER PROCESS
BY UPDATING NOTICING
REQUIREMENTS STREAMLINING THE
PUBLIC'S ENGAGEMENT PROCESS. AND
BY PROVIDING THE WATER BOARD A
BETTER PICTURE OF THE TRANSFERS
TO COMMENT IN A GIVEN WATER YEAR
. THE STATUTE WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED. IN THE WATER
TRANSFER PROCESS WAS PASSED OVER
THIRTY YEARS AGO AND MINIMAL
UPDATES HAVE BEEN MADE SINCE
THEN. OUR MODELING OF HYDROLOGY
IS EVOLVING AND SO IS HOW THE
PUBLIC ENGAGES IN STATE PROCESS
THESE. AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
FIVE PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
UPDATES TO THE TEMPORARY WATER
TRANSFER PROCESS WHILE PROVIDING
THE WATER BOARD THE FOR NEEDED
TO PLANET STAFFING NEEDS FOR THE
WATER YEAR. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS CHARLES DELGADO
POLICY DIRECTOR OF SUSTAINABLE
CONSERVATION. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SAID THAT MANAGE CHARLES
TOOK OUT A POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
SUSTAINABLE CONSERVATION A
SUSTAINABLE CONSERVATION IS A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
ON BRINGING TOGETHER BUSINESSES
LANDOWNERS COMMUNITIES AND
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES TO MEET THE
WATER NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENT PEOPLE AND ECONOMY
FOR CURRENT AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS. IN SEEKING OUT
COLLABORATIVE SOLUTIONS WE HAVE
A PARTICULAR FOCUS ON ADVANCING
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT AND ACCELERATING THE
STEWARDSHIP OF NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS AND WATERWAYS AND
I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR JOAQUIN
ARAMBULA. CALIFORNIA IS ONCE
AGAIN EXPERIENCING A PROLONGED
DROUGHT YOU MUST RECKON WITH HOW
TO BEST MANAGER VALUABLE WATER
RESOURCES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITIES A
NATURAL HABITATS. IN ADDITION TO
INCREASINGLY FREQUENT DROUGHT
CONDITIONS ARE STATEMENT ALSO
ADAPT TO THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE OUR WATER SUPPLIES. TO
MEET THE CHALLENGES OF THE
FUTURE WE MUST DEVELOP TOOLS AT
ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT TO
ALLOW WATER MANAGERS TO ADAPT
FROM RELIANCE ON THE RELATIVELY
PREDICTABLE RAINFALL AND RUNOFF
PATTERNS OF PRIOR DECADES. TO
CAPTURING WATER WHEREVER AND
WHENEVER FEASIBLE AND MOVING
SUPPLIES TO WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED
WHETHER FOR DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS IRRIGATION ARE
RECHARGING DEPLETED AQUIFER IS.
THIS BILL IS A STEP FORWARD
BUILDING THE WATER MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS NOW
AND INTO THE FUTURE. AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY FIVE WOULD
STREAMLINE THE WATER TRANSFER
PETITION REVIEW PROCESS BY
MODERNIZING THE NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR TRANSFERS.
ENCOURAGING COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN STATE PERMITTING
AGENCIES ENABLING BETTER
COORDINATION BETWEEN
TRANSFERRING PARTIES AND GIVING
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD THE FLEXIBILITY IT
NEEDS TO REVIEW WATER TRANSFER
APPLICATIONS IN A TIMELY AND
EFFICIENT MANNER. IMPORTANTLY
THIS BILL CONTINUES TO ALLOW THE
BOARD TO APPLY ITS EXPERTISE AND
AUTHORITY IN SUCH A MANNER AS TO
PREVENT ANY POTENTIAL ABUSES OF
THE WATER TRANSFER SYSTEM MAY
RESULT IN INEQUITABLE OUTCOMES
FOR STAKEHOLDERS. AND ENSURE THE
RIGHTS OF DOWNSTREAM USERS WHILE
REDUCING THE REGULATORY BURDEN
FOR BENEFICIAL TRANSFERS THAT
CAN BE USED FOR DRINKING WATER
SUPPLIES MULTI BENEFIT
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE PROJECTS
HABITAT RESTORATION PRESERVATION
OF OUR AGRICULTURAL SECTOR AND
ALL OTHER USES. THERE'S MUCH
WORK TO BE DONE TO ENSURE THAT
WE GIVE WATER MANAGERS AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS THE TOOLS
TO MAKE THE WISEST DECISIONS
POSSIBLE. AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
FIVE THE MAKING SMART CHANGES TO
THE WATER TRANSFER SYSTEM TO
ENABLE MORE EFFICIENT USE OF OUR
WATER SUPPLIES IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. THE
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL SIGNAL THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO ADAPTING
TO THE CHANGING WATER
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE LIVE IN.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST HER AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OTHER SUB. IN THE ROOM. OPERATE
IN MATH TO THE PHONE LINE SPACE
FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE
AND THEN ZERO APPEARANCE SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO SUPPORT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME AND CHECK.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE
AND THEN THEY OFFER IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
ONE MOMENT VENTURE. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE THIRTY EIGHT.
SENATE APPRECIATE OFFERINGS
COMMITTEE WORKING HELP YOUR
ADDRESS ONE OF OUR CONCERNS
REGARDING CERTAINTY IN THE
TEMPORARY WATER TRANSFERS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TREAT ALL
OF OUR REMAINING CONCERNS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. WE NEED A
MOTION. THE SECOND. DR M. YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DOLLY NOBODY DALY
NOT VOTING NAZARIAN. BENNETT
BENNETT I BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT
VOTING FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE KALRA
KALRA HI LEVINE MR MERRY SUCI
WHEN RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I SMITH SMITH NOT VOTING
VEHICLE ONE THE VALLAPUDUA I.
WARD WARD I. THANK YOU WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. TWO BILLS. RIGHT. YEAH.
THIS IS A MORE. YEAH. AFTER.
WE'LL START WITH TWO TWO ZERO
ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR- COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WANT
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS AND WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR ON THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL BOB THIS
IS I THINK A VERY IMPORTANT
MOMENT FOR US IN CALIFORNIA IS
CERTAINLY AN IMPORTANT MOMENT.
FOR ME AS A LEGISLATOR WE HAVE A
REAL PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA WITH
THE ISSUE OF WATER AND GETS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF EVERY ONE OF
US HERE TO CAREFULLY CONSIDER
AND TRY TO ANALYZE THE
SITUATION. AND MY CONCERN IS
THAT. OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
HAS SIMPLY MISREPRESENTED WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. IF YOU READ THE
LETTER IN OPPOSITION IT ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY FOCUSES ON THE FACT
THAT THIS TAKES LOCAL CONTROL
AWAY. AND SOMEHOW IMPLIES IT
GOES TO THE STATE. AND THAT'S
JUST A MISREPRESENTATION AND SO
FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE STILL
UNDECIDED ABOUT THIS BILL I HOPE
YOU WOULD CAREFULLY CONSIDER.
THAT THERE IS A AN INCENTIVE FOR
PEOPLE WHO. EXTRACT WATER- UP TO
UP ALWAYS OPPOSE ANYTHING THAT
MIGHT AFFECT THEIR ABILITY TO
TAKE WATER OUT OF THESE IN
IMPORTANT OVER DRAFTED
AQUIFER'S. BUT IN THIS SITUATION
WE HAVE HAD A NUMBER OF YEARS
WITH CIGNA TO TRY TO FIND OUT
WHAT'S WORKING AND WHAT'S NOT
WORKING AND WE SIMPLY HAVE ONE.
AREA WHERE WE HAVE A PROBLEM.
THE GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES ARE IN CHARGE OF TRYING
TO GET THE BASINS INTO
SUSTAINABLE YIELD AND YET THEY
DON'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO.
DEAL WITH THE NEW WELLS THAT ARE
GOING IN SO YOU HAVE THOUSANDS
IN CALIFORNIA THOUSANDS OF NEW
WELLS GOING IN AT THE SAME TIME
THAT A GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCY IS TRYING
TO GET THAT BASIN AND SO THIS
BILL DOES JUST ONE SIMPLE THING
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THEIR
ANALYSIS SAID WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM. AND THAT IS
WE HAVE A DISCONNECT BETWEEN
THOSE WHO ARE MANAGING THE BASIN
FOR SUSTAINABLE YIELD. OKAY AND
THOSE WHO ARE APPROVING THE
SINKING OF THE NEWWELLS AT THE
SAME TIME YOU CUTE YOU JUST IT
JUST MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO PUT
APPROPRIATELY DO THE WORK. AND
SO ALL THIS BILL DOES IS SIMPLY
SAY THE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCY NEEDS TO
BE. CHECKED IN WITH AND I HAVE
TAKEN SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS I
THINK THAT THE AQUA
REPRESENTATIVES HAD SOME GOOD
POINTS AND ARE AMENDMENTS HAVE
ADDRESSED ALL OF THEIR ISSUES IN
TERMS OF NOT HAVING THIS BE
DUPLICATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROCESS OF NOT HAVING THIS BE
OVERLY BURDENSOME ON THE G. S.
H. SO WE'VE STREAMLINED THAT
DOWN. WE'RE SENSUALLY CODIFYING
THE GOVERNOR'S- THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER- WERE CLEANING
UP SOME OF THOSE DETAILS AS WE
DO IT BUT I IMPLORE YOU WHILE
WE'RE WORKING ON THIS PLEASE LET
THIS MOVE FORWARD SO THAT WE AS
A STATE LEGISLATURE CAN DISCUSS
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE WHICH IS
THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN
GROUNDWATER WELL. APPROVALS AND
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY AND WITH ME HERE TODAY-
TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE BILL
IS KYLE JONES FROM THE COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. I
THINK MORNING KYLE JONES
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND SO OF
THIS BILL AS AMENDED BY THE
COMMITTEE- THIS IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE AND WE RECOGNIZE IT'S
ABSOLUTELY IMPERATIVE THAT WE
CONNECT AND CLOSE THE GAP
BETWEEN LAND USE PERMITTING
DECISIONS. AND SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT IN ORDER
FOR SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT TO SUCCEED AT A STOP
APPROACH TO THE PROLIFERATION OF
NEW WELLS NEXT TO COMMUNITY
WELLS NEXT TO DOMESTIC WELLS AN
EXTRA CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- I
APPRECIATE THE MOMENTS TRYING TO
FIND A WAY FORWARD AND CODIFYING
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER AND GIVING
THE LEGISLATURE CHANCE TO SHAPE
HOW THAT. EXECUTIVE ORDER WILL
PLAY OUT AND GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE FEEDBACK
THAT WE'RE GETTING FROM ON THE
GROUND IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS FEEL LEGISLATION.
THERE'S BEEN SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SIX FOUR YEARS THAT WE HAVE NOT
BEEN IN DROUGHT IN CALIFORNIA.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE IS
GOIG TO BE A DROUGHT EMERGENCY
GOING FORWARD AND IT'S GOING TO
BE FREE POINT- WE CAN EXPECT
EXECUTIVE ORDERS TO CONTINUE AND
I THINK IT'S- BETTER THAT WE
FIND A WORKABLE SOLUTION THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE. RATHER THAN
RELYING ON EMERGENCY ORDERS.
EVERYBODY OR SO- WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT I'M HERE FOR ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. ENTERED
DRIVE WHICH DAY AND WOULD LIKE
TO YIELD FIRST MY TIME BELIEVE
ANOTHER WITNESS ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE ROUTE MARTINEZ
SO ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
OPERATOR. A MOMENT. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU. YES MY NAME IS RICK
MARTINEZ AND I'VE BEEN A BOARD
MEMBER FOR THE DIFFICULT
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICT FOR
SEVERAL YEARS I AM CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THAT AB TWENTY
TWO ZERO ONE TO PROTECT DRINKING
WATER FOR COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I'VE BEEN FIGHTING
FOR WATER JUSTICE FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS OF LEGAL WORK
ALONGSIDE PETER JARVIS. DURING
THE FARMWORKER MOVEMENT FOR
CLEAN WATER I DO HAVE BEEN
DIFFICULT FOR MOST OF MY LIFE.
BECAUSE OF LAW COMMUNITY INTO
GREAT COUNTY ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
PEOPLE WHERE MOST THIRD.
FARMWORKERS FOR DECADES OUR
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN NEGLECTED
THAT WE'VE SUFFERED FROM BY JAKE
CONTAMINATION ISSUES FOR THE
YEARS THAT MEANT WE COULDN'T USE
OUR WATER COMING OUT OF THE-
GAP. DO CORD LIKE MANY OTHER
COMMUNITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY HAS BEEN. I HAD TO RELY
ON COSTLY BOTTLED WATER FOR
EVERYDAY TASKS LIKE COOKING
DRINKING SO THAT OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS. DON'T HAVE A HAVE THAT
YOU. QUARTERLY INTO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WE WILL LEVERAGE A ONE
POINT MILLION DOLLARS THANK GOD
AND GRILLED REPLACE COMING WELL
. IT DID NEARLY TO THE THREE
PROVIDE STATE WATER FOR MYSELF
AND MYNEIGHBORHOOD FIRST TIME
IN MANY YEARS. THE LAST YEAR THE
BRAND NEW COMMUNITY GOING TO
WONDER WELL WOULD. MAKE BUT IN
THE END BASIN INCREASED RISK OF
BREAKING. NEWS HAS BECOME. THIS
IS BECAUSE THE AGRICULTURE WHILE
THAT WAS PROVIDED PERMITTED TO
BE DRUG ACROSS THE STREET. DO IT
NOW. NEARBY IDENTICAL DEPT LAST
SUMMER. THE COUNTY APPROVED THIS
NEW WELL WITHOUT THINKING ABOUT
THE IMPACT ON OUR COMMUNITY NOT
ONLY REQUIRED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE. SET BACK WHICH HAS FAILED
PROTECT. NICHOLAS THAT WE DON'T
KNOW OF THE GIVEN TO US THE NEW
WHAT WITH DRILLED AND NO
PROSPECT X. AT FOR A TWO. ON THE
WELL PREVENT. WE WHERE WERE THAT
SHARED A HOLIDAY AREA THE NEW
WOULD DIRECTLY THAT ARE WHY
SUPPLY. AN INCREASE IN THAT. OF
OCT. AS A MEMBER OF THE CULT OF
THE COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICT
BOARD I AM GETTING MANY CALLS.
AND CONCERNS ASSEMBLY. THAT THE
DECREE. AND THE LACK OF WATER
COMING FROM MY CAPS. ARE BRAND
NEW WHILE ITS RATING BECAUSE THE
COUNTY DID NOT PROTECT THAT. ARE
EVEN GIVEN THE WARNING. ONE MADE
IN THE NEW ACT. WELL I'M FOR
THAT'S ALL THE NEW. ARE NOT
UNIQUE. TO GET. BUT AS. WE DID
GET THAT BUT YOU KNOW HE'S
ACROSS STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BASICALLY AGE OF WATER AT. AB
TWENTY TWO ZERO ONE THAT CORRECT
BILL THAT WILL HELP ENTIRE CAN
MAINTAIN GREAT WATER ACCESS WITH
KIDS LEARNING HUMAN RIGHTS HELLO
FOR ABOUT. FEW YEARS WHAT IS THE
- LIFE AND WE NEED IT THIS
PROTECTION IN THE LONG TERM NOT
JUST GOING THEY DIDN'T ALLOW THE
DRAW. OR GET A RED CLAY STATE OF
THE- I COMMUNITY ON THAT I YOU I
HIGHER JUNE FOR YOUR I. TODAY ON
BE COULD TWO ZERO ONE THANK YOU
THE COMMITTEE YOU FOR TIME THANK
YOU. FIGURE ONE ELSE AND SO IN
THE ROOM AND- TODAY. GOOD
MORNING AS FAR HAVE NATURE OF
ITS IN SOME THANK YOU. HI
ENTRAPMENT PRICE RIGHT A BY
VOTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO WOULD YOU OF THE VOTE ON
THE OF THE LEE OF WOMEN WE
ADVOCATE THE ENVIRONMENTAL NORTH
COUNTY AND CIVIC WELL WE ARE
JUST A PART THANK YOU. CHAU
BOTTERILL OF ON BEHALF OF
COMPANY BECAUSE COMPLIANCE AND A
TEN CALIFORNIA KEEPERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MOVED OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. I'M
SORRY. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BOB REAP WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS TESTIFYING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE VALLEY I
WATER COALITION AND SOLANO
COUNTY WATER AGENCY. THE VALUE
ADD WATER COALITION CONSISTS OF
FORTY THREE WATER DISTRICTS JUST
DITCH COMPANIES MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE WATER TO
FARMS THROUGHOUT THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. EVERYONE OF OUR MEMBERS
AS A MEMBER OF A GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCY. THEY
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
COMPLETELY UNDERCUTS LOCAL
CONTROL THE KEY TENETS
UNDERPINNING THE ENTIRETY OF
SIGMA. THE BILL IMPOSES SEVERAL
NEWMANDATES AND FOR THE RECORD
MADAM CHAIR THE COMMITTEE IS
BEING ASKED TO VOTE ON A BILL
TODAY THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
AMENDMENT LANGUAGE ALL WE HAVE
ARE BULLETS IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS SO IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
FOR US TO REALLY SPEAK TO THE-
TO THE BILL. WHEN WE JUST HAVE
BULLET POINTS BUT BE THAT AS IT
MAY- ACCORDING TO ANALYSIS THE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE A COUNTY TO
OBTAIN WRITTEN VERIFICATION FROM
THE GSA BEFORE ISSUES A PERMIT
FOR A NEW WELL. OR NOT TO
RESCIND EXISTING WELL. THIS WILL
OVERRIDE COUNTY ORDINANCES BASED
ON MINISTERIAL APPROVAL OF WELL
PERMIT APPLICATIONS. AND LIKE
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
WHICH INVOLVED ZERO STAKEHOLDER
CONSULTATION IT WILL LEAD TO ONE
OF THREE OUTCOMES. NO NEW WELLS
INCREASE LITIGATION OR A FULL
SEQUEL ANALYSIS FOR EVERY WELL
PERMIT APPLICATION. SECOND THE
BILL REQUIRES A GSA TO DETERMINE
THAT A NEW OR ALTERED WELL WILL
NOT IMPACT OTHER NEARBY WELLS OR
CAUSE SUBSIDENCE THAT IMPACTS
NEARBY INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS IS
DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO
ASSESS. AND THIS REQUIREMENT
GOES FAR BEYOND THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER SIGMA ALREADY AUTHORIZES
THE GSA TO IMPOSE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS ON NEW WELLS TO
MINIMIZE WELL IN FOR
INTERFERENCE. IT AUTHORIZES
GSA'S CONTROL GROUNDWATER
EXTRACTIONS AND AUTHORIZES GSA'S
THE CONSTRUCTION TO REGULATE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW WELLS. THIRD
THIS BILL REQUIRES A GSA TO
ALLOW FOR A THIRTY DAY PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD BEFORE MAKING A
DETERMINATION ABOUT A PROPOSED
WELL. IN RENDERING DE FACTO ALL
PERMIT APPLICATIONS AS
DISCRETIONARY THIS BILL WILL ADD
NEW DUPLICATIVE PUBLIC COMMENT
PROCESS OF THOSE ALREADY
ESTABLISHED UNDER SYKORA.
FINALLY THIS BILL APPLIES ITS
MANDATES TO ALL MEDIUM AND HIGH
PRIORITY BASINS RATHER THAN JUST
BASS AND SUBJECT CRITICAL OVER
DRAFT. SIGNATURE EATS BASIN
SUBJECT TO CRITICAL OVER DRAFTED
DIFFERENTLY THAN OTHER MEDIUM OR
HIGH PRIORITY BASINS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF WHICH ARE BEING
SUSTAINABLY MANAGED. THE BASIS
FOR DESIGNATING BASINS IS MORE
ABOUT POPULATION IN THE RELATIVE
RELIANCE ON GROUNDWATER'S FOR
SUPPLY. PLUS THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD APPLY TO JUDICATA BASINS
WHICH CONFLICTS WITH THEIR
TREATMENT UNDER SIGMA FOR THESE
REASONS WE- STRONGLY ENCOURAGE A
NO VOTE THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING-
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
BRENDA BASS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO R. ONE. AB TWENTY TWO
OH ONE WOULD CREATE A NEW
PERMITTING REGIME FOR
GROUNDWATER WELLS THAT WILL
NEGATIVELY IMPACT AGRICULTURAL
BUSINESSES THE PEOPLE IN OTHER
BUSINESSES THAT RELY ON A
THRIVING AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY
BANK ECONOMY FOR THEIR
LIVELIHOODS. AND ON FOOD
SECURITY IN CALIFORNIA THE BILL
IMPOSES STRICT NEW MANDATES ON
HOW GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES OR GSA'S- MUST OPERATE
AND MANAGE THEIR OWN GROUNDWATER
BASINS THIS IS AT ODDS WITH THE
POLICY WILL GOALS OF SICK NOT
WHICH FOCUS ON LOCAL CONTROL.
SIGNALED ACKNOWLEDGES THAT NOT
EVERY GROUNDWATER BASINS THE
SAME AND THAT NEW SINGLE
MANAGEMENT SOLUTION IS THE RIGHT
FIT FOR EVERY BASIN. AB TWENTY
TWO R. ONE DOES NOT AFFORD GSA'S
THE NECESSARY FLEXIBILITY TO
TAILOR MANAGEMENT TO LOCAL
CONDITIONS. SIGMA IS ALREADY
BEING IMPLEMENTED EVEN WITHOUT
THIS BILL SIGMA IS ANTICIPATED
TO RESULT IN THE FOLLOWING OF UP
TO ONE MILLION ACRES OF FARMLAND
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. OVER
THE NEXT FEW DECADES WHICH WERE
ONCE WHICH WILL RESULT IN THE
LOSS OF EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
JOBS AND COST BILLIONS IN LOST
FIRM REVENUE. THIS WILL ONLY
EXACERBATE THESE IMPACTS IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AGRICULTURE
IS THE MAIN ECONOMIC DRIVER.
WITH MANY INDUSTRIES AND JOBS
TIED DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY TO
FARMING SUCH AS TRANSPORTATION.
FINANCE AND MORE. ADDITIONALLY
CAL AGRICULTURE PROVIDES
NECESSARY FOOD SUPPLIES TO THE
STATE AND THE REST OF THE
NATION. AT A TIME WHEN PRICES
ARE RACING ARE RISING DUE TO
INFLATION AND SURFACE WATER
SUPPLIES ARE ESSENTIALLY
UNAVAILABLE FOR AGRICULTURE.
FURTHER LIMITING THE SUPPLY
WATER SUPPLY FOR CROPS MEANS
THAT CALIFORNIANS MAY HAVE AN
EVEN HARDER TIME ACCESSING
AFFORDABLE AND HEALTHY FRUITS
ANDVEGETABLES. WELL THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE WAITED NEAR THE
GOVERNOR'S RECENT EXECUTIVE
ORDER THE KEY DIFFERENCES AND
PERMANENCE WE SHOULD WORK
THROUGH THE BEST WAYS TO ACHIEVE
WHAT THE DIRECTIVES IN THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER BEFORE CODIFYING
AN APPROACH. AND MODIFYING THE
LOCAL CONTROL GUARANTEED AND
CIGNA THIS IS JUST NOT THE RIGHT
TIME FOR THE SPELL. THANK YOU.
SIR ANY OTHER OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
DANNY MERKLEY DIRECTORA
RESOURCES FOR- THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU AND- WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS PREMATURE
MEASURE THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION THE ROOM. HELP WITH.
GO BACK TO THE PHONE LINES- FOR
SUPPORT AND OP WOULD DO THOSE
THANK YOU. OKAY IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY TWO ALL ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT
IT'S FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS MICHAEL JERRY ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMITTEE ALLIANCE OF
FAMILY FARMERS- I HAVE A BRIEF
TWEENER- I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR STAFF ON THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
CAPS ON. AB TWENTY TWO OH ONE
CAPTIVE NOT HAVE A POSITION ON
AB DE TWENTY TWO OH ONE RIGHT
NOW- THEY WILL BE REVIEWING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
SMALL FAMILY FARMERS WILL NOT BE
UNDULY BURDENED BY THE BELL. TWO
ITEMS THAT CAP IS ALREADY FLAG
AND WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORED THE COMMITTEE STAFF ON.
OUR DEFINING WAT THE ALTERATION
OF EXISTING WHILE MEANS AND WHAT
ARE WHILE REPLACEMENT- WITH THE
SAME OR LESSER EXTRACTION
CAPACITY SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN
THE BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE SEVEN TWO IN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS
DANIELLE BLACK TO HIDE WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WE CURRENTLY HAVE
THAT POSTWHAT THE MEN DID ON
EIGHTY TWO TWO ZERO ONE THIS IS
THE REAL ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO
HAVE A LONG TERM SOLUTION NOT
THAT WHEN THERE'S A DROUGHT
EMERGENCY. WELL WE HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL AND PRINT WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND HELP TO
FIND THE PROJECT THE PATH
FORWARD THINKING AGAIN. THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WITHIN OPPOSE UNLESS
SOME POSITION YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE MORNING THIS IS
ERIN WILL LAY ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO R. ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO LINE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
DENNIS ALL THE ON IN BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SEES THAT SHE'S JIM
COOPER GRANT. WE ARE OPPOSING
HANDED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS YOU
KNOW SOMETHING HAPPENED BALLS
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT
THE LINES FIVE AIRLINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING REBECCA BACK IN
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S DINNERS
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WESTERN
AGRICULTURAL PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT ASSOCIATION BUT TRUMP AND
HELP WITH THE CASE AND OTHER
APPLICANTS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
TO GO TO LINE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JACK WELCOME WITH A GLOBAL GROUP
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WHITE GRAPE
GROWERS KERN COUNTY WATER AGENCY
THE KINGS RIVER INTERESTS AND
MODESTO IRRIGATION DISTRICT. AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MICHAEL
CLAIBORNE ON BEHALF OF
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL PROJECTED
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT ON THE LINE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CARE AND MEMBERS TRICIA
GERINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN GROWERS TO
WITH ANYBODY GETS ON THE PHONE
LINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND I'M SURE WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS. MISTRIAL OF. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR PRECIADO IT TO
THE AUTHOR. THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT FILL IT SEEMS LIKE
IT'S GOT FIVE CHALLENGES A LOT
OF FOLKS OUT THERE SOME ON BOTH
SIDES AND WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE SOME COMMUNITY SAID
YOU STRUGGLE WITH WATER WE HEARD
ONE OF THOSE- TESTIFIES TODAY-
IF YOU CAN HELP US TO UNDERSTAND
THE RATIONALE IN APPLYING THESE
NEW- UNFUNDED MANDATES ACROSS
THE BOARD. TO ALL MEDIUM AND
HIGH PRIORITY BASINS SINCE MANY
OF THESE BASINS ARE EDUCATED
ALREADY THEREFORE TIGHTLY
CONTROLLED- MOST OF THEM. IT
SEEMS LIKE OUR SUSTAINABLE AT
LEAST IT SEEMS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS SUSTAINABLE IN ARE
ALREADY HAVING THE YIELDS. THEY
DON'T HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS TO
WIPE BROADLY. CAST YOUR BILL
ACROSS ALL OF THESE SUSTAINABLE
DISTRICTS. VERSUS JUST FOCUSING
IN ON THESE THAT HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE QUESTION I APPRECIATE IT
THERE ISN'T AN ATTEMPT TO TRY TO
CAST THIS ACROSS ALL OF THEM. IT
ONLY APPLIES TO THE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AREAS WHERE THERE
IS A GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY. AND AND SO PLACES THAT
ARE IN BALANCE ARE NOT PLEASE
DON'T DON'T APPLY AND I
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
COMMENT MADE EARLIER ADJUDICATED
BASINS ARE ALSO NOT. J. JUDICATA
BASINS. THIS DOESN'T- THIS
DOESN'T AFFECT THE WATER MASTER
TERMS OF DECISIONS OF WATER
AFTER TO MAKE IT REALLY IS
FOCUSED ON THE AREAS WHERE THERE
IS A GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY THAT'S BEEN CREATED BY
THE STATE BECAUSE THE STATE HAS
A CONCERN. ABOUT THE OVERDRAFT
PROBLEMS OF THAT PARTICULAR
AQUIFER SO HOW DOES THIS HOW DO
YOU ADDRESS THE FACT THAT UNDER
SIGMA SIGMA AUTHORIZES THE GSA'S
TO IMPOSE SPACING REQUIREMENTS
ON A NEW WELL CONSTRUCTION- TO
MINIMIZE THE WELL INHERENT.
CONFLICTS THAT MAY ARISE- IT
SEEMS LIKE GSA'S DUE TO THEIR
WORK- WITH OFTEN ONLY ODDER
ALTERING BUT THE FOCUS ON LOCAL
CONTROL DOES SEEM TO BE LOST HOW
DO YOU ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE WELL I AGAIN. I'M A IF YOU
DON'T MIND THE TERMS OF THE
RESPONSE I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT'S
LOCAL CONTROL LOS THIS DISTRICT
IS THE GSA'S ARE LOCAL SO IT'S
NOT LOCAL CONTROL LOST NUMBER
AUTHORIZES JUST SPACING. THAT
DOES NOT AUTHORIZE- HE YOU KNOW
HE IS THE WELL CONSISTENT WITH
THE WITH THE GSA'S. END RIGHT
NOW THE COUNTIES ARE AT A
MINISTERIAL LEVEL AND MANY GSA'S
HAVE HAVE. PROBABLY NOT EVEN
GOTTEN AROUND TO ALL OF THOSE
OTHER REQUIREMENTS THEY BEEN
FOCUS ON THESE OTHER THINGS YET
I THINK WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES
A FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION. IS
SHOULD WE BE ON RECORD AS SAYING
WORK WE SHOULD KEEP THESE WELLS
IN THESE OVER DRAFTED BASINS
THAT HAVE GSA'S CHIU WE KEEP
THEM AT THE MINISTERIAL LEVEL.
WHERE THE COUNTY IS NOT EVEN
ALLOWED TO DO- A SIGNIFICANT
REVIEW THEY HAVE TO FOLLOW THE
MINISTERIAL PROCESS WHICH MEANS
NO DISCRETION NO ANALYSIS IF YOU
MEET IF YOU MEET THESE TWO OR
THREE REQUIREMENTS YOU GET YOUR
WELCOME. THAT JUST SEEMS YOU
HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY WE WERE. ONE OF
THE LAST STAGE. IT THE COUNTRY
T. DO ANYWAY. OF GROUND. WITH
THE WIN WE DIPLOMA PASSED
YESTERDAY. WE SHOULDN'T BE ONE
OF THE LAST STATES THAT ALSO
SAYS. WE'RE GONNA KEEP TO NEW
WELLS MINISTERIAL THE APPROVED.
IN A NIGHT I'M I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SINCERITY OF THE
QUESTION BECAUSE I WOULD JUST
OFFER IN VENTURA COUNTY. WE
ACTUALLY DID THIS WE SAID NO NEW
WELLS- TEN AM IMPLICATED WE CAME
UP WITH THIS. AND IT WAS
BITTERLY FOUGHT. UNTIL WE DID.
AND WHEN WE DID IT EVERYBODY
SAID IT WAS THE BEST THING THAT
HAPPENED. BECAUSE THEY WERE
CONCERNED THEY DIDN'T KNOW HOW.
ONE FARMER DID KNOW HOW TO SAY
TO THE OTHER FARMER HEY AB I
DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD PUT THAT
WELL AND- BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA
FACT MY FAR. CAN THEY WERE THEY
WERE SORT OF LOOKED BUT THIS
JUST STAB. A FRAMEWORK WHEN WE
DID THAT AND I VIEW THE
OPPOSITION. COMING
UNDERSTANDABLY FROM THE EXACT
SAME SPOT. AND I HAVE HAD I HAD
DOZENS OF AG INTERESTS COME UP
TO ME AND SAY I COULDN'T SAY IT
AT THE TIME. I'M REALLY GLAD YOU
DID THAT BECAUSE IT WAS REALLY
AFFECTING OUR ABILITY. EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE SPACED IT WAS
AFFECTING OUR ABILITY AND YOU
YOU FIND IT LOTS OF AG INTEREST
IN LOTS OF OTHER PEOPLE WHO. ARE
TERRIFIED THAT TOO MANY NEW
WELLS ARE GOING TO GO AROUND
THEM AND IT'S GOING TO AFFECT
THEIR ABILITY. THIS JUST SAYS
GSA'S PLAY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
NOT AT THE STATE LEVEL GSA'S
PLAY A LOCAL ROLE HERE IN TRYING
TO HELP. DEAL WITH THAT
SITUATION AND THAT'S WHY I THINK
AT A MINIMUM I REQUEST GIVE US A
CHANCE TO LET THE AMENDMENTS
ACTUALLY COME OUT OF LEDGE
COUNCIL. THEN WE CAN HAVE A- A
MORE ROBUST ANALYSIS OF THIS
BILL AND ALL THE AMENDMENTS
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN AS WE'VE
TRIED TO MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD.
RIGHT AND I APPRECIATE THAT AND
I DO I. I BELIEVE THAT'S A VERY.
DIRECT AND SINCERE ANSWER BUT I
THINK THE PROBLEMATIC ISSUE
BECOMES WITH THE GSA'S AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THEY START UP
TRUMPING LOCAL LAND RIGHTS THE
OVERLYING LANDOWNER HAS A RIGHT
TO THE WATER WITH. WHICH IS
UNDERNEATH HIS PROP OR FOR
PROPERTIES AND THAT THE THERE IN
LIES THE PROBLEM THAT YOUR BILL
SETS FORTH. YOU HAVE ANOTHER
COUNTY MADERA I'LL JUST MENTION
THAT ALREADY IN LITIGATION
BECAUSE WHAT THEY'VE DONE IN
THEIR GSA IS THEY'VE TAKEN THE
OVERLYING RAIN WATER THAT FALLS
ON THE LAND AND- HAVE TOLD THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT FORMING ON
THAT LAND. THAT THAT WAS THAT
WATER THAT FELL ON THEIR LAND.
THEY'RE ONLY ENTITLED TO. TEN OR
AS MUCH AS 25% OF THAT WATER IS
WHAT THEY CAN USE FOR THEIR LAND
ALL THE REST HAVETO BE ROUTED
OVER TO THOSE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
ARE GETTING. THAT SEEMS LIKE A
TO TAKING TO ME. AND I THINK
THAT THAT BECOMES THE THAT
HAPPENS WE THIS BILL. IT BECOMES
AN EXTENSION OF THE TAKING OF
WATER RIGHTS FROM ONE AND GIVEN
TO ANOTHER AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS SETTING FORTH IT ALSO
SETS FORTH WHAT. POTENTIALLY CAN
BECOME AN OUTRIGHT MORATORIUM ON
ACTIONS IN TIME WHILE IT MAY NOT
SIGNING IT OVER THE IMMEDIATE
MOMENT. OVER TIME IT WILL. IF I
COULD ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF. IT TWO
THINGS THAT PICKED THE
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES. GENERALLY ARE HAVE A
VERY STRONG REPRESENTATION FROM
THE AG INTEREST- AND THEY'VE
MADE IT ALL THE ONES THAT I'VE
BEEN EXPOSED TO SO IT'S NOT LIKE
WE HAVE A HOSTILE AGENCIES OUT
THERE BUT WE DO WE MAKE WE HAVE
AND SEE IF WE AYE WE MAY HAVE
HAD AND IN SOME SITUATIONS- BUT
HOLES THIS DOES IS THE
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY. HAS TO VERIFY THAT IT
DOESN'T VIOLATE THE POLICIES
THAT THEY HAVE AT THIS
PARTICULAR TIME IT DOESN'T ALLOW
THEM TO TAKE AWAY WATER RIGHTS
FOR EVERYBODY IT IT JUST SIMPLY
HAS THAT- BUT BUT AT SOME POINT
IN TIME. THAT MAY BE A
PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCE WHICH
IS MANAGED SHOULD SHOULD ALL
WILL STAY MINISTERIAL. NO MATTER
HOW BAD THE SITUATION GETS NO
MATTER HOW MUCH NEGATIVE IMPACT
IT COULD BE SHOULD DO SHOULD THE
WELL STATE MINISTERIAL FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE PRIVATE PROPERTY
RIGHT OWNER THAT IS THERE AT
SOME POINT IN TIME. I WE HAVE TO
SAY AT LEAST LET US HAVE THE
GSA'S WAY IN END TO OFFER A PATH. THAT'S WHERE WE BACK TO THE
SIGNET SITE OF IT SIGNAL WITH
CERTAIN. OP FOCUS AND CONTROL
OVER IMPOSING STATE MANDATES AND
I THINK NOW WE'RE TRYING TO
TRUMP THAT AND GIVE A LITTLE
HIGHER READY TO. PRIORITY TO THE
GSA SO I THINK IT IS A
PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCE. AND I
WOULD SAY BECAUSE THE GSA'S NEED
THAT'S ONE THING THAT GOT MISTER
GSA'S NEED THAT IF THEY'RE GOING
TO GET THE- IF THEY'RE EVER
GOING TO GET THE BASIN INTO
SUSTAINABILITY. THANK THEY HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO SAY WHETHER WE'RE
GONNA HAVE FIVE THOUSAND NEW
WELLS IN HERE OR TEN THOUSAND
NEW WELLS IN THERE IT DOES MAKE
A DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF GETTING
IT INTO SUSTAIN I WOULD JUST
OFFER TO THE MEMBERS. I THINK WE
NEED TO LET SIGMA MAKE THAT. I
DO. TYPE OF INACTION OR ACTION
RULING WITHIN THEIR BODY AND
THEIR THEIR- HOURS AND NOT LEAVE
IT TO US HERE TODAY TO MAKE THAT
DECISION AT TEN AND I WOULD
OFFERED THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IT GIVES THEM THE
AUTHORITY TO SAY. HEY THIS IS
THE WE THINK THESE WELLS ARE
PROBLEMS AT ALL THANK YOU.
THIRTY OTHER MEMBERS LIKE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. FIFTY G.
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER BENNETT YET
YES I WOULD AND I APPRECIATE
INDULGENCES ALLOWING US TO HAVE
A LEGISLATIVE BODY BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY HAVE DEBATE IS HEALTHY
SO I APPRECIATE THAT FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY
RESPOND TO THE ARGUMENT THAT
KEEPS BEING MADE THAT THIS IS
TAKING AWAY LOCAL CONTROL THAT
KEEPS BEING SAID IT WAS SAID
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND LETTER
OF OPPOSITION A RESPECTFULLY OUT
OFFERS IS JUST NO EVIDENCE OF
SAYING IT'S TAKING AWAY LOCAL
CONTROL IT'S ACTUALLY GIVING
LOCAL CONTROL TO THE LOCAL GSA-
THAT IS OUT THERE- AND AT THIS
THE SECOND THING- YOU KNOW WHAT
AS I AS I MENTIONED- WE HAVE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE COMING. UP
IT AS IMPORTANT AS THIS ISSUE IS
IT SEEMS TO ME WE OUGHT TO-
ALLOWS US TO MOVE FORWARD SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN TRULY ANALYZE-
THE AMENDMENTS TO BILLS EXCEPT
WE HAVE MANY MANY PLACES WHERE
OF THIS BILL IS GOING TO BE
REVIEWED AS IT MOVES FORWARD-
THE FINAL TWO POINTS BOB WE
SHOULD ALL CARE- AT THE END I
GROUP WHICH IS GENERALLY WE
SHOULD ALL CARE THAT ONE
THOUSAND DOMESTIC WELLS WENT DRY
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY. ALONE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. NOW THAT'S A-
EVERYBODY SAYS I WANT TO BE IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
SHOULD TAKE SERIOUSLY THOUSAND
DOMESTIC WELLS THAT'S DRINKING
WATER FOR PEOPLE WENT DRY IN ONE
COUNTY. AND THE IT M. ANSARI IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY RIGHT NOT
NOT IN MY COUNTY THANK YOU FOR
THAT IN. IN THE IN THE PERSONAL
QUESTION I THINK WE SHOULD ALL
ASK OURSELVES IS DO YOU WANT TO
BE ON RECORD AS SAYING. EVEN
THOUGH THAT'S THE CASE ALL WELL
PERMITS SHOULD STILL BE JUST
MINISTERIAL THERE SHOULD BE
NOTHING ELSE EXCEPT THE MINISTER
A REVOTE REVIEW FOR NEW WELL. I
JUST DON'T THINK YOU WANT TO BE
ON RECORD OF THAT AND SAYING I
DON'T EVEN WANT TO CONSIDER A
BILL. ANYMORE AS WE GO FORWARD
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. THAT YOU ALLOW THIS
BILL TO CONTINUE TO MOVE. AND
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
IT WITH COMMITTEE STAFF THANK-
NEED TO MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK. CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DOLLY NO TELLING
NO. NAZARIAN. BENNETT HI BENNETT
I BIGELOW BIGELOW NOW FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA KALRA POLAR
AYE LEVINE. MURATSUCHI WHEN
RUBIO SALAS SMITH SMITH NOW THE
VALLAPUDUA YEAH THE PROVIDE NO
WARD WARD I. LEAVE IT OVER FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND MR
FINISHER TAKING UP I'M. TWENTY
EIGHT ZERO FIVE. THANK YOU. THE
FORM OF. THANK YOU NUMBER. HI
CHIEF I ON. THIS ONE BE A MEMBER
OF. PROBLEMS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR OF TODAY A
PRESENTER AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
FIVE IT IS- BUILT BY- OUR CHAIR
WHO'S ABSENT TODAY- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- OUR CAUGHT ON AND- THE
BILL MAKES CHANGES TO THE
EXISTING REGIONAL CONSERVATION
INVESTMENT STRATEGY PROGRAM.
KNOWN AS R. C. I. **** AT THE
DEPARTMENT EFFICIENT WILDLIFE
TAKING CONSERVATION ACTION
ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S CRUCIAL AS
WE FACE CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
EXISTING PROGRAM CREATED BY- AB
TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN CREATED THIS OF
VOLUNTARY NON REGULATORY
PROCESS- AND ONCE DEVELOPED- AND
R. C. I. S. CAN BE USED TO GUIDE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE CONSERVATION
EASEMENTS I THINK I WANT TO JUST
TRY TO GET AT THE ESSENCE OF IT
BASICALLY THERE ARE. PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND OTHERS WHO HAVE TO
DO MITIGATION ENVIRONMENT BEFORE
THE SEQUEL- IMPACTS THAT THEY
HAVE WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
CREATE A AND IDENTIFIED LIST OF
POTENTIAL WELL THOUGHT OUT
MITIGATIONS THAT PEOPLE COULD
INVEST IN AND COULD GET
MEDICATION CREDIT FOR. THIS BILL
TRIES TO BOTH CLEAN UP THAT
PROCESS OPEN THAT PROCESS
ABSOLUTELY CAN DO MORE OF THIS
AND CERTAINLY FITS WITH THE
THIRTY THIRTY GOALS OF THE STATE
ACCOUNT. ARGUE WITH THAT- HERE
TO TESTIFY A. AS- LUCAS- FAIR
RICK'S AT THE NATURE CENTER
EXPRESSION SERVICE SHE AND CHRIS
BEAL- FROM A RESOURCE LAW GROUP
WILL BE ON THE PHONE THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THE CONTRACTS ON BEHALF
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY ARE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB TWENTY TO
FIVE AM AS A SUMMER BENNETT
SAID- THE BILL MAKES
ENHANCEMENTS TO THE EXISTING OUR
SAY YES PROGRAM WHICH WAS FIRST
CREATED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN- YOU
KNOW THE RCS PROGRAM HELPS CHIEF
IMPORTANT STATE PRIORITIES IN
APPROVED RCS PROVIDES STRATEGIC
GUIDANCE FOR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENTS NEEDED TO ACHIEVE
THE STATE'S THIRTY BY THIRTY BY
DIVERSITY GOALS. ADDITIONALLY
ARE SAY ESTAS CAN HELP INTEGRATE
CONSERVATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION TO
MEET BOTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CLIMATE ADAPTATION GOALS AB
TWENTY TO FIVE IS NEEDED TO
REFINE THE RCS PROGRAM
PROCEDURES AND STANDARDS TO
ALLOW IT TO ACHIEVE THESE
IMPORTANT GOALS MORE EFFICIENTLY
AND EFFECTIVELY. BASED ON
LESSONS LEARNED DURING THE
PROGRAM PILOT PHASE OF THE PASS
FIVE YEARS- BEFORE OF THE RCS-
SUCCESS INTO. TO EIGHTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY TO FIVE WOULD ALSO REMOVE
THE STATE WHY CAP ON TOTAL
NUMBER. IS RESPECT THEIR QUESTOR
AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR. DOING THAT. THANK
YOU OPERATOR TO MOVE TO THE
WITNESS AND- I AM A WITNESS ON
THE PHONE FIFTH. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CHRISTY- THE RESOURCES LAW GROUP
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY OH FIVE IT AND- THEY
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE- I WAS INVOLVED IN THE
ORIGINAL BILLS WELL TWENTY
EIGHTY SEVEN AND- IT SUPPORT AND
CANCER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU WE
HAVE ANY SUB PORT IN THE ROOM.
OPERATOR COMMITTEE THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT OH FIVE. I'M
SURE WE HAVE NO SUPPORT IN Q. AT
THE THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM- INTO THE PHONE LINES
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONES.
GIVE YOUR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT OH FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
AGAIN IT'S ONE AND THEN THERE
FOR IN OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
NO UP LISTENING TO AT THIS TIME
AN OBJECT THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE
A MOTION. WE NEED A SECOND. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION QUESTIONS.
MISTER BENNETT WHICH LIKE CLOSE
FACTLY ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS DOLLY HI DALY AYE
NAZARIAN BENNETT BENNETT I
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA KALRA.
LEVINE LEVINE AYE MURATSUCHI. NO
WHEN RUBIO SALAS SALAS I SMITH
SMITH I THE VALLAPUDUA WARD BY
WARD I THINK HE WILL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS MR
MCCARTY YOU'RE PRESENTING FOR MR
COOLEY. THANK YOU. TWENTY SIX
THIRTY THREE.
THE BILL YES THANK YOU ARE
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF MR
COOLEY WHO'S OUT ILL TODAY- I'M
A CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL SO NOT
I'M NOT JUST PRESENTING BUT I AM
A- IN FULL SUPPORT- THIS IS A
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE BILL BUT IT RELATES
TO. OUR PROBLEM WITH
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL- WHEN HE SAID THIS BILL
TODAY WHICH WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S SPECIAL PARK LANDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FIRST BY
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF WORKING ON THIS AND ACCEPT
THAT COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU. MANY OF CALIFORNIANS
REGIONAL PARKS AND OUTDOOR
SPACES PROVIDE IMPORTANT
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RESIDENTS WHILE PRESERVING
CRITICAL NATURAL RESOURCES AND
PUBLIC SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE.
AMENITIES OUTDOOR SPACE AS LONG
REPRESENT LEVEES SUPPORT- FLOOD
CONTROL AS WELL AS FISHING
SPECIES AND DEGRADATION OF THESE
AREAS IMPACT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND IMPACT OUR PUBLIC SAFETY.
OUT RECENTLY- WE'VE SEEN MANY
INCIDENTS OF FIRES I KNOW SOME
OF THE MEMBERS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WHEN YOU'RE IN
SESSION YOU MAY HAVE SEEN FIRES
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS AROUND
HERE. 99% OF TIME THERE FROM THE
LEVEES AROUND HERE AND
UNFORTUNATELY THEY'RE CAUSED BY
UNSANCTIONED HOMELESS CAMPS A
YESTERDAY IN THE FRONT PAGE OF
THE SECOND BE THE SIERRA CLUB
ASK THE COUNTY AND CITY IS STEP
UP ENFORCEMENT OF AN- PERMITTED
CAPPING THEIR WITH A DOCUMENT
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY SIX FIRES LAST
YEAR. I'M AT THESE HOMELESS
CAMPS- THESE STRONG WINDS PUSH
THESE FIRES THROUGHOUT THESE
ENCAMPMENTS AND NOT ONLY-
IMPACTED VEGETATION- AND THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO POSED A
RISK TO THE CAMPERS THEMSELVES.
ADDRESSING THIS ENVIRONMENTAL
DAMAGE AND PUBLIC SAFETY HAZARDS
IN OUR SPECIAL PARK LANDS IS
CRITICAL TO PROTECTING THE LIFE
SAFETY OF ALL OF OUR PARKS OUR
VISITORS OUR NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES AND ENSURING PARK
SUSTAINABILITY. HI THIS BILL IS
BORN OUT ABOUT OUR PARKWAY HERE
IN SACRAMENTO WHICH HAS EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE VISITED EVERY
YEAR BUT REALLY IT'S ABOUT SOME
OF THESE SPECIAL PARK. LANDS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. LASSEN
SOME WOULD SAY WERE YOU GOING TO
TELL PEOPLE TO GO IF THEY ARE
HOMELESS. THERE ARE CERTAIN
PLACES THAT YOU CAN'T CAN'T IF
YOU'RE HOMELESS WE DON'T HAVE
CAMPSITES ON THE STATE CAPITOL
RIGHT OUTSIDE HERE. WOULD ALLOW
CAMPSITES ON THE FOOTBALL FIELD
THAT PRINTER HIGH SCHOOL THAT WE
DON'T ALLOW CAMPSITES- UNDER
HALF TO MILLION SEVENTY. WOULD
ALLOW HOMELESS CAMPS ON THE
BEACHES OF LAKE TAHOE WE THERE
ARE CERTAIN PLACES WHICH FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS BUT PUBLIC
PLACES. ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS WE
SAY THE SUN NOT BE SANCTIONED A
CAMPSITE SO WE REALIZE THAT WE
ALSO REALIZE THAT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
DIRECT- THE HOMELESS WHERE TO
GO. AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE TAKING
THESE AMENDMENTS HERE FOCUSING
ON- REQUIRING THAT THE TO BE
PLENTY OF NOTICE BEFORE- WE HAVE
AN ACTION RELATED THESE
CAMPSITES. AND MAKING SURE THE
INDIVIDUALS ABOUT A PLACE FOR.
SHELTER AND SAFE GROUND- WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THIS
MORNING AND I HAVE WITH ME
STEVEN GREEN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE AMERICAN RIVER. ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU. BUT THANK YOU AND
HAVE A GREATLY APPRECIATE IT
THIS LEGISLATION IS HERE AS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY SAID.
THERE WERE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX FIRES. ON THE AMERICAN RIVER
PARKWAY. IN THIS PAST YEAR.
WE'VE ALREADY HAD FIRES AGAIN
THIS YEAR. AND IT'S GETTING
WORSE. ONE OF THE MOST.
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT HAPPENED.
IS THAT A- HABITAT RESTORATION
PROGRAM AN ACADEMIC PROGRAM AT
SAC STATE UNIVERSITY. HAD BEEN
UNDER WAY RIGHT THERE ON THE
PARKWAY FOR FIVE YEARS. IT WAS
ENTIRELY WIPED OUT BY THESE
FIRES. THIS IS OVERDUE WE HAVE
GOT TO DO SOMETHING TO PROTECT
THIS CRITICAL HABITAT THIS
RECREATION AREAS THAT ARE THERE.
AND I'M VERY PLEASED THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY HAVE
PROVIDED- PROVISIONS TO THE
BUDGET THAT WOULD PROVIDE FOR
HOUSING FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY PARKING ON THE PARKWAY
AND I REALLY HOPE YOU WILL
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU. THERE
ANY OTHER OF SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
TODAY. A PRETTY CLEAR THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE
AND THEN THE- FEAR IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO SUPPORT
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AND THE ROOM. THIS IS.
A STEVEN MAKING CONFIRM. GET OFF
THE OFFER WHAT DO I GO YOU
AROUND I. REPORTER YOU CAN BE
FROM THE IF YOU WITH. THIS IS A
MEDICAL TERM. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE. I'M HOMELESS
ADVOCATE FOR THE HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE. THERE LIVING IN THE
STREETS OF CITRUS HEIGHTS THAT'S
PRIMARILY WHY WORK. WHEN MORE
VERSUS BOISE PASSED. IT'S NOT
PERFECT BUT IT WAS A WAY TO
WHERE PEOPLE COULD ACTUALLY
SLEEP. AND IT'S A BIG DEAL I
MEAN I GO HOME EVERY NIGHT AND I
GET TO GO TO SLEEP. AND THESE
PEOPLE DON'T. OKAY I FOUGHT FOR
TWO WOULD HAVE FOR YEARS IN SOME
INCIDENCES JUST TO GET AGENCIES
TO CAPITULATE THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY BE THERE. I HAD TO STOP
SAYING WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
THERE. AND START SAYING YOU'RE
IN CONTEMPT OF COURT. WHEN I
STARTED SAYING THAT. WHOLE
DIFFERENT STORY YES MISTER SUCH
AS THEY CAN BE HERE WE'RE SORRY
. IT'S LIKE WHILE OKAY SO THIS
IS THE REAL THING THIS IS A DO
YOU KNOW THIS ISN'T JUST
SOMETHING WE MADE UP. EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
CIRCUMVENT THIS LAW. UNDER RULE
IT. THE VIOLATIONS AGAINST THAT
RIGHT NOW BUT WHO CARES RIGHT
THESE ARE JUST HOMES PEOPLE.
THEREFORE. THE DESCRIPTION OF
THE BILL SAYS YOU'RE GOING TO
REMOVE ILLEGAL ENCAMPMENTS. WELL
ACCORDING TO MARTIN VERSUS
BOISE. THESE ARE NOT ILLEGAL
ENCAMPMENTS THIS IS JUST THEY
BELIEVE IT'S A PLAY ON WORDS
JUST THE DEMONIZED THOSE PEOPLE
. I STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT YOU
CHANGE THE WORD ILLEGAL. AND
REMOVE IT FROM THERE. BECAUSE
IT'S DEMONIZING PEOPLE I
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT IF
NOTHING ELSE THIS GUY HERE THAT
CAME HERE TODAY BEFORE YOU. IS
ASKING YOU FOR THAT JUST CHANGE
THAT WORD BECAUSE I GUARANTEE
YOU EVEN IF THIS BILL PASSES
DOWN THE ROAD PEOPLE ARE STILL
GOING TO BE DOWN THERE AND
THEY'RE GONNA BE SAYING NO
THERE'S A FEDERAL LAW. THAT SAYS
WE CAN BE HERE I GUARANTEE THAT
THANK YOU PLEASE SUMMARIZE. THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU WANTED TO PUT A
REMOVED. THE STYLES OF THE
PEOPLE. IT WAS A NATURAL
DISASTER YOU WOULD HAVE FEMA
TRAILERS YOU WOULD HAVE
PORTAPOTTIES YOU HAVE FOOD HE
WOULD HAVE LOVED YOU HAVE LITTLE
TEDDY BEARS. THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING TO
GIVE THEM. IS NOTHING BUT KILL
TO MONEY IT'S- IT'S A DROP IN
THE BUCKET. AND IT'S NOT GOING
TO CHANGE ANYTHING THANK IF YOU
COULD HOUSE ALL THOSE PEOPLE YOU
WOULD HAVE ALREADY DONE IT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR LISTENING YES
THE AND I SO MUCH I HOPE YOU
VISIT THANK YOU. TO THE NEXT. HI
SHARON MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARCUS
DAHLE THE AND I'M THE SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE ON
HOMELESSNESS AT HOUSING
CALIFORNIA ON THANKS TO MISTER
SANCHEZ WHO CAME THIS MORNING
AFTER READING ABOUT THIS BILL
AND THAT LOCAL NEWSPAPER AND
DECIDE IT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO RAISE HIS VOICE SO ALIVE I'M
GRATEFUL FOR HIS TESTIMONY-
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
PARK LANDS ARE CRITICAL
RESOURCES FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
AND ECOSYSTEMS HOWEVER WE SHARE
THE CONCERNS OF OUR PARTNERS AT
THE ACLU OF THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND OTHERS. THAT THIS
BILL THREATENS TO FURTHER
CRIMINALIZE DESTABILIZE AND
DISPLACED ARE MOST ECONOMICALLY
DEPRIVED NEIGHBORS IN THE MIDST
OF AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS A RECENT
REPORT BY THE ACLU DETAILED THE
WAYS IN WHICH- LOCALITIES ACROSS
THE STATE ARE INCREASING
ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS THAT
EFFECTIVELY BAN ON HOUSE PEOPLE
FROM PUBLIC SPACES AND MANY
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN DISPLACED AND
BANISHED FROM PUBLIC SPACES THAT
MIGHT BE SAFER OR MORE PROXIMATE
TO SERVICES BECAUSE OF LAYER
UPON LAYER OF LOCAL ORDINANCES
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT PRACTICES
THAT SWEEP ENCAMPMENTS. BUT
BEYOND THE CIVIL AND HUMAN
RIGHTS IMPLICATIONS WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL WILL ALSO FAIL TO
ACCOMPLISH ITS STATED GOAL OF
CLEARING PARKLANDS OF SO CALLED
ON PERMITTED CAMPERS BECAUSE AS
STATED PEOPLE HAVE NOWHERE TO GO
OUR SHELTER AND HOUSING SYSTEMS
ARE BEYOND CAPACITY PEOPLE WHO
ENTER OUR STATE HOMELESS
RESPONSE SYSTEM THROUGH THEIR
LOCAL CONTINUUM OF CARE
TYPICALLY WAIT BETWEEN NINE AND
TWELVE MONTHS BEFORE THEY'RE
CONNECTED WITH HOUSING AND WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT SWEEPING
ENCAMPMENTS FUNCTIONALLY MAKES
HOMELESSNESS WORK WORSE. BY
DESTABILIZING PEOPLE- REMOVING
THEIR BELONGINGS THAT AND
IDENTITY DOCUMENTS THAT CAN BE
MISTAKEN FOR TRASH CREATING
CRIMINAL RECORD BARRIERS AND
ROADING TRUST BETWEEN OUR OWN
HOUSE NEIGHBORS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HOWEVER WHAT WE'RE
NOT SUGGESTING IS TO ACCEPT THE
STATUS QUO THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO ENSURE PEOPLE ARE NOT
FORCED TO SLEEP IN OUR SPECIAL
PARKS IS THE SAME THING THAT
WOULD END THEIR HOMELESSNESS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SERVICES AND
WHEN NECESSARY INTERIM SHELTER
FACADE TO FACILITATE ACCESS TO
HOUSING. LOCAL PARK DISTRICTS
COULD BE EQUIPPED TO BUILD
PARTNERSHIPS WITH SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO ENGAGE PEOPLE
THROUGH ON GOING OUT REACHING
CONNECT THEM TO RESOURCES.
UNFORTUNATELY WE CANNOT SUPPORT
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY THREE.
TWELVE TWENTY SIX THIRTY THREE
WHICH WE FEAR CREATES A NEW PATH
TO DISPLACE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND SEEKS TO BLAME
INDIVIDUALS MOST IMPACTED. BY
OUR HOUSING CRISIS FOR A HOST OF
SYSTEMIC ISSUES WITHOUT OFFERING
REAL SOLUTIONS. THANKS FOR TIME
. THANK YOU SO MUCH IS THERE
ANYMORE- OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. OPERATE THE SMOKE TO THE PHONE
LINES IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
FOR IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY THREE MY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE
AND THEN THEIR OFFER ANY
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THE SHERIN REPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO TO DISCUSS THE L.
BEHALF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE'RE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY THE PRIMARILY THE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE. SIXTEEN YOUR LOOK.
SENIOR US SENIOR ATTORNEY AT THE
NATIONAL HOMELESSNESS LAWCENTER
CRISTINA BOWERMAN IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT TO
THE LINE EIGHTY SIX THE LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU PATTI PANICCIA
BURSTING YOUR HOUSING ATTORNEY
AT JUSTICE IN AGING FOR THE
REASONS THAT- THE WITNESSES HAVE
STATED WE OPPOSED TO SPELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
AN OBJECT THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THIRTY
QUESTIONS. MR WARD. THANK YOU I
WANT TO- THANK YOU AND MISTER
COOLEY FOR RAISING THIS ISSUE I
AIN'T FULLY APPRECIATE HOW DIRE
THE SITUATION IS AMONGST THE
RIVER HERE IN SACRAMENTO INDEED
MANY OF OUR PARK LANDS ACROSS
THE STATE- INCLUDING SOME IN MY
DISTRICT AS WELL- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN VEXING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ABOUT HOW TO
RESPONSIBLY ENGAGE AND ASSESS
AND REMEDIATE- ENCAMPMENTS THAT
ARE FRUSTRATING TO THOSE THAT
CARE ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
CERTAINLY PRESS WRITTEN TO THE
GENERAL COMMUNITY AT LARGE- I AM
ALL BALL JUMP AHEAD TO SAY THAT
I DON'T FEEL THAT I'M IN A
POSITION TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. I DON'T WHILE THE COUPLE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT- YOU
KNOW BE INTERESTED IN ANSWERING-
THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE IS THAT I
KNOW AND WE KNOW THIS FROM MY
OWN I KNOW THIS FROM MY OWN
EXPERIENCE IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THAT THERE ARE BETTER PATHWAYS
TO BE ABLE TO DO JUST THAT TO
ENGAGE INDIVIDUALS TO RESOLVE
HOMELESSNESS WHERE IT SAT TO
HELP ASSIST THEM ON THE RIGHT
PATH WAYS WE NEED DO A BETTER
JOB AND THAT TOO IT DOES NOT
DISCOUNT THE CRISIS THAT WE HAVE
IN FRONT OF US AND SOME OF THE
IMPACTS ARE HAVING BOTH
ENVIRONMENT INTO THE GENERAL
COMMUNITY. AND THAT'S
FRUSTRATING- I AM CONCERNED THAT
THIS BILL IS DRAFTED IS GOING TO
BE- EITHER- YOU DON'T RENDER
MOOT TO OR OTHERWISE ON DONE
BUYING THAT FEDERAL BOISE MARTIN
VERSUS BOISE DECISION- I KNOW
THAT THEIR AMENDMENTS IN HERE
THAT- I THINK IS DRAFTED YOU
KNOW YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE NOTICE TO- TO CAMPERS TO
BE ABLE TO PRESERVE AND STORE-
PERSONAL PROPERTY- AND ALSO THAT
YOU KNOW SERVICE WORKERS AND-
THOSE POINTING INDIVIDUALS
TOWARDS. WOULD BE AVAILABLE- TO
HELP THEM- QUOTE- EVERY EFFORT
SHALL BE MADE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THESE AND IT SAYS IT IT'S A BIG
ENOUGH THAT I'M WORRIED THAT NAY
ON BOISE WILL STILL UNDO- AND A
LOG WITH THIS INTENTION AS WELL.
AND THEN YOU MORE BROADLY. I
WONDER WHY WE WOULD EVEN NAY THE
TO HAVE DOESN'T NEED OF A SPY.
PART PLAN. AT ALL I THAT FOR
MINE POSITION AND YOU CAN CALL
ME IF I'M WRONG. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MANAGE THE PARK PLANS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO- ENFORCE ORDERS.
UNDER BOISE SUBJECT TO THE
CONDITIONS BE IN PLACE THAT
THERE IS A ALTERNATIVE AND
POSITIVE PATHWAY TO RESOLUTIONS.
SO I'M NOT SURE THAT WE EVEN
NEED THESE OTHER NATIONS BECAUSE
I BELIEVE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ALREADY HAVE THE EMPOWER MEN IF
THEY ARE DOING THINGS THE RIGHT
WAY- SO FOR THOSE REASONS I WILL
LIKELY BE OPPOSING THIS BILL I
WELCOME- THE FEEDBACK YOU HAVE
TO SOME OF THOSE POINTS BUT I.
AGAIN DON'T- DISAGREEING WITH
DEAN- THE INTERESTS AND- THE
SOLUTIONS THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
FIND- TO BE ABLE TO HAVE YOU
KNOW A HEALTHY BALANCE WITH WITH
THOSE THAT THAT WANT- HEALTHY
OPEN SPACES AS WELL FOR THEIR-
PUBLIC ENJOYMENT. THE RESTAURANT
. I'M SURE IT HAD BEEN VERY
CLOSE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS
COMMENTS I'M JUST ON THE OTHER
OF THE LINE WHICH IS I'M IN A
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD- BUT THE ONE AREA
THAT I WOULD THE- LITTLE.
RESERVE MY VOTE ON THE FLOOR ON
IS TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
AUTHORS. ARE ABLE TO MAKE SOME
CLARIFICATIONS AND MODIFICATIONS
I THINK WE HAVE A WE HAVE A HUGE
CHALLENGE WITH THE WHOLE
HOMELESS- SITUATION HERE AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY
OF- THE GENTLEMAN THAT THAT CAME
AND JUST SO YOU KNOW THE BILL
HAS ALREADY BEEN CHANGED. THE
WORD ILLEGAL HAS BEEN TAKEN OUT
AND IT'S BEEN CHANGED ON
PERMITTED SO VIEW ACCOMPLISH AT
LEAST ONE OF ONE ONE OF YOUR
GOALS. BUT THAT BALANCE BETWEEN-
PROTECTING OR PRESERVING SOME
OPEN SPACE AREAS- AND- STILL
HAVING PLACES FOR PEOPLE WEEK WE
CAN'T SIMPLY CRIMINALIZE. BEING
HOMELESS AND I KNOW THAT'S NOT
YOUR JANET ALL BUT WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE PLACES AND SO
I'M HOPEFUL WHEN I READ THE
TERMS OPEN SPACE. THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COULD TAKE ANY ALL
WHAT WHAT DOES THAT MEAN DOES
THAT MEAN DESIGNATED ZONED OPEN
SPACE OR DOES THAT MEAN ANYTHING
THAT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT CALLS
OPEN SPACE. CAN NOW BE
RESTRICTED- IF I NEED NARAL. I
NEED THOSE THINGS NARROWED DOWN
TO BE MORE CLEAR. DO I THINK
THAT WE SHOULD DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THE FOR. THEY ABOUT RIVER.
AND ESTUARIES AND A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF CAMPING THAT WE GET AN
IDEA RUN DOES AND ALL THAT
ABSOLUTELY SENSITIVE HABITATS
ABSOLUTELY. SENSITIVE CRITICAL
PLACES IN A IN A IN A COMMUNITY
YOU KNOW THE LAWN OF THE STATE
CAPITOL- BUT- WHAT I WANT I AM I
JUST IT FEELS A LITTLE TOO BROAD
AT THIS POINT TIME SO I- BUT I
DO WANT TO. TAKE TO CONTINUE
THIS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION FOR US TO
HAVE IN THE HOPES THAT YOU GUYS
CAN NARROW THAT DOWN A LITTLE
BIT MORE AND ALSO THE OTHER
THING I WOULD. LIKE TO ASK THE
OFFICERS TO CONSIDER IS A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS TO IDENTIFY
WHERE PEOPLE CAN CAMP- YOU KNOW
WHERE CAN THEY SO THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE OF SOME COMMUNITIES WILL
PUSH THE ENVELOPE AND SAY NO
PLACE NO PLACE IN OUR COMMUNITY
THAT'S ALL. WE'RE GONNA WE'RE
GONNA FIND A WAY DOESN'T EVERY
EVERY COMMUNITY HAS IN THERE
SOMEPLACE THAT IF YOU NEED TO
FALL ASLEEP YOU'RE NOT TEN
UNPERMITTED PERSON FALLING
ASLEEP- THERE. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT. THAT'S
RIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE TO YEAH.
YEAH THE FEW OF THESE THE THESE
ISSUES- SO THERE ARE. IN OF OUR-
WHERE WE KNOW WE DON'T. YOU KNOW
WHAT TO MAKE BEING- HOMELESS A
CRIME A FELONY WE DON'T WANT TO-
CRIMINALIZED POVERTY BUT THERE
ARE CERTAIN PLACES THAT YOU
CAN'T CAN'T FOR VARIETY REASONS
I WOULD SAY NEW CURRENT DISTRICT
MR WORD. ON THE BEACH YOU CAN'T
HAVE A CAMPSITE THERE WITH A
HUNDRED PEOPLE. IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE BEACH IN THE HIGHEST THAT
JUSTICE IT'S A PUBLIC PLACE FOR
WRITER REASONS WE DON'T PERMIT
THAT. AND I THINK WE'RE SAYING
OTHER CERTAIN PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT THERE PUBLIC
PLACES BECAUSE OF. THE FACT THAT
YOU KNOW THE PUBLIC APPRECIATES
THAT PUBLIC ACCESS AND ALSO FOR
AN AMOUNT OF REASON VERY MINOR
REASONS THAT WE SHOULD NOT HAVE-
UNPERMITTED. CAMPSITES I DO
COULD CURRENT 1100% MISTER
BENNETT THAT WE SHOULD OFFER
PEOPLE. A ALTERNATIVE AND THAT
GOES BACK TO THE BOISE. ISSUE
AND IN HERE WE TALK ABOUT THAT
IN THIS IN THE AMENDMENT THAT WE
TOOK TODAY. AND IN MY EYES. GOOD
ON HERE TO THE PARKWAY WHICH IS
LITERALLY TWO MILES FROM HERE
AND COULD FIND. FIVE HUNDRED
CAMPERS WITHIN TWO HOURS. WITH
JUST WALKING DOWN HERE. I THINK
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO GO TO
PEOPLE SAID OKAY HE CAN'T CAN'T
HEAR. BUT YOU CAN GO OVER TO.
THE PARK AND RIDE IT AT THAT
THAT- ET. YOUR SPACE J. TWENTY
FIVE. FOURTEEN GO TO OTHER CREEK
AND POWER IN YOUR SPACES DEL
TWELFTH. THOSE ARE YOUR TWO
OPTIONS BUT YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T
STAY HERE. YOU'RE RIGHT WE NEED
TO GIVE PEOPLE A SAFE PLACE TO
GO. AND FRANKLY- THAT'LL GIVE
MORE SAFETY FOR THEM. THE LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE VICTIMS OF CRIME
ARE ACTUALLY THE HOMELESS THERE
IF YOU READ THE STORIES ABOUT.
ASSAULTS OF WOMEN DOWN THERE IT
IS HORRENDOUS FOR PEOPLE THAT
ARE HOMELESS DOWN THERE. AND SO
IT'S AS PUBLIC SAFETY FOR A LOT
OF SURE WE HAVE. THE SAFETY MY
STORIES AND THERE WAS A WOMAN
RAPED AND MURDERED UP ON THE
PARKWAY A COUPLE MONTHS AGO AND
THAT HE RIPPED FROM THE
HEADLINES BUT THERE ARE PLENTY
OF OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE
HOMELESS WHO ARE- YOU KNOW.
VICTIMS OF CRIME DOWN THERE- AS
WELL SO- WE DO NEED TO OFFER
PEOPLE PLACE TO GO. BUT THE
RIVER THE OTHER SAD TRUTH OF
THIS IS I'VE BEEN DOWN THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF CLEANUPS INCLUDING A
FEW WEEKS AGO AND TALKED TO
SOMEONE ADVOCATE IS THERE. AND
THEY SAY THAT SOME OF THE
CAMPERS. THIS IS THEIR LIFE THEY
DON'T WANT TO GO. EVEN IF YOU
OFFER THEM. A MOTEL VOUCHER FOR
TWO WEEKS NOW I HAVE STAFF HERE.
I HAVE MY DOG THIS I'M GOOD
HERE. AND THEN SO I THINK WE
NEED TO SAY THAT THERE'S CERTAIN
PLACES THAT YOU DO YOU CAN'T BE
AND YOU CAN GO TO AN ALTERNATIVE
PLACE FOR A SAFE GROUND BUT THIS
IS NOT ONE THAT YOU SHOULD-
CONTINUE TO. TO STAFF. SO THANK
YOU. WE HAVE A MO. BRING IT
SECOND. TO LIKE. AND OUT
THINKING I HAVE A BUSY SO ASK
THE RIGHT THINKING THINK YOU.
HIS THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PAY AS AMENDED TO. DAHLE I TELL
I IN THIS. BENNETT BENNETT I.
BIGELOW I FREE. FREE I GARCIA
KALRA LEVINE LEVINE AYE
MURATSUCHI WHEN. RUBIO SALAS
SELLS ICE SMITH SMITH I BE
APPROVED ONE. WARD NO WORD NO. I
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MINDED MEMBERS SENATOR. MY FULL
OF MINIATURE MEMBERS MINDFUL OF
EVERYBODY'S TIME IT'S PRETTY
SIMPLE BILL. SECOND I REGION I
FELT THANK YOU. THEY MAY NOT
THIRTY SUPPORT IN THE ROOM SIR.
OPERATOR FIFTY PHONE LINES IN
SUPPORT. DIFFERENCE ARE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO FAIR
IN SUPPORT AND SB FORTY TWO.
HONESTY FORTY TWO THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO SUPPORT YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM.
OPERATORS ANY OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES. GIVEN OPPOSITION OF
SB FORTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. QUESTION THE
STRUGGLE OF. YOU'RE JUST TRYING
TO CLARIFY BY ADDING THE
PREVIOUS KNOWN NAME. ON THE
THIRD FISH AND WILDLIFE
DEPARTMENT HAS FOR THAT. EXACTLY
INNOCUOUS RIGHT THANK YOU AND
THE MONEY'S ALREADY IN THE
BUDGET GOT IT. THANK USE WE HAVE
A MOTION A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE BETTER TONIGHT BOTH.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS DALI DALI I IN
THIS AREA BENNETT. BENNETT I
BIGELOW BIGELOW I FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA. GARCIA I
KALRA KALRA I. LEVINE LEVINE AYE
MURATSUCHI WHEN RUBIO SALAS
SALAS SIZE SMITH SMITH I VIEW
PULA. WARD WARD I THE FAILURE.
YEAH RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT. THE
COLLAPSE OF THE ON THE BILL'S
THANK MOMENT. WITH THAT.
QUIRK-SILVA. AB TWENTY NINE
NINETEEN WAS PULLED FROM THE
AGENDA TODAY BY THE AUTHOR- AT
THIS TIME WE WOULD LIKE TO- ASK
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
COME CAST VOTES. YOU WILL BEGIN
TO GET THE FULL RUN THROUGH- FOR
THOSE MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE SO
THAT THEY CAN LEAVE AND WE'LL
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. THE ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I. MURATSUCHI
WHEN. SMITH NUMBER ONE. YES NO
SMITH NO. AT SALAS FROM NOT
VOTING TO KNOW. AND WARD- HIGH
WORD I. WELL HOLD IT OPEN FOR A
FEW ABSENT MEMBERS- ITEM NUMBER. TWO ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I KALRA KALRA
I MURATSUCHI WHEN SMITH. WARD BY
WARD I THINK YOU WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR ANY ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM
NUMBER THREE. ABSENT MEMBERS
NAZARIAN. FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I-
SU CHI WHEN SMITH. SMITH I.
THANK YOU ALL FOR THAT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS A NUMBER FOR.
ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN. KALRA
KALRA I. LEVINE LEVINE I'M
MURATSUCHI WHEN. THE VALLAPUDUA
THERE BE A CIRCUIT COULD WELL I
. WE WILL HOLD THAT FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WE WILL TAKE ITEMS
NUMBER FIVE FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND
NINETEEN ON CONSENT. ABSENT
MEMBERS NAZARIAN BIGELOW BIGELOW
I KALRA KALRA I MURATSUCHI. WHEN
SMITH SMITH BY THANK YOU WILL
HOLD THE CONSENT CALENDAR OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER
SIX ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN.
LEVINE LEVINE AYE MURATSUCHI
WHEN. FOR IT THANK YOU WILL HOLD
THE ITEM FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NOT
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. ABSENT
MEMBERS NAZARIAN LEVINE. IT'S A
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN. LEVINE I
MURATSUCHI NO ONE. THAT'S IT HE
WILL HAVE THE AND OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS I REMEMBER ANY.
ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN LEVINE
LEVINE AYE MURATSUCHI WHEN. HE
WILL HOLD A ADAM OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
TWENTY FOUR TWELVE ABSENT
MEMBERS NAZARIAN. LEVINE LEVINE
AYE MURATSUCHI WHEN. THANK YOU
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY ONE ABSENT
MEMBERS NAZARIAN BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING. FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I KALRA KALRA I. LEVINE
LEVINE AYE MERE SUJI. SMITH
SMITH NOT VOTING. YOU HOLD OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AT ELEVEN AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY THREE ABSENT
MEMBERS NAZARIAN. GARCIA. OKAY.
BUT IT BUT WE DON'T SCHOOLS ARE. YEAH. PARKLAND GARCIA NOT
VOTING. KALRA KALRA NO.
MURATSUCHI WHEN RUBIO. TO BE
APPROVED BY. THE VALLAPUDUA I
THINK YOU WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
FIVE. ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN.
LEVINE LEVINE I MURATSUCHI WHEN
. THAT'S IT HE WILL HOLD IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. I AM
THIRTEEN IS PULLED IN FOURTEEN
SB FORTY TWO. ABSENT MEMBERS
NAZARIAN. MURATSUCHI WHEN RUBIO
. VEHICLE DOOR THE FOOD WHAT I.
HE WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY TWO OH ONE. ABSENT
MEMBERS NAZARIAN GARCIA GARCIA I
LEVINE. MURATSUCHI WHEN. RUBIO
SALAS. THAT'S IT THE WHOLE THE
M. OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
OH FIVE. ABSENT MEMBERS IN HIS
ARIAN GARCIA GARCIA I KALRA
KALRA I MURATSUCHI WHEN RUBIO.
THE VALLAPUDUA COULD WHAT I
THINK HE WANTS TO SERGEANTS TO
CALL THE OFFICES OF ABSENT
MEMBERS AND WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR APPROXIMATELY TEN
MORE MINUTES. I AM FROM. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. OKAY.
SACRAMENTO. SOURCE SURE. YEAH
YES TÌM. WHAT PARK IS WE NEED.
COMMITTED TO GO. SHE SAYS THAT
EVERYTHING. SO COOL. YEAH BAKER
BUT IT'S DONALD. OKAY BUT THE
GOVERNMENT CAN. DON'T RECORD.
WHAT ARE. THANK YOU FOR. SHE
YEAH CONNECTION. OKAY THIS CALL
CHRIS SO- YEAH. BRAINER RIGHT.
YEAH OKAY YEAH. SORRY HOUSE MADE
WEAPONS YEAH OKAY THE- AND GET
THEM THANK YOU HAVE. A FEW MORE.
ALL AGAIN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB EIGHTEEN
ELEVEN. ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN
KALRA MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
WHEN NOT VOTING WHEN NOT VOTING
ALL THE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
AND NUMBER TWO AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE. ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN.
MURATSUCHI MERCI GI WHEN I WHEN
I HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. FIVE NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY TWENTY TWO ABSENT MEMBERS
NAZARIAN MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
. WHEN HI WELL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB TWENTY ONE OH EIGHT ABSENT
MEMBERS NAZARIAN MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I'D WHEN. STATE AND
NOT VOTER WHEN NOT VOTING WILL
HOLD THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ITEM NUMBERS. FIVE
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND NINETEEN ON
CONSENT. ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I WHEN.
CONSENTWHEN I WILL HOLD THE
CONSENT CALENDAR OPEN FORABSENT
MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER SIX AB.
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE. ABSENT
MEMBERS NAZARIAN MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I'VE WHEN I HOLD OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN.
ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I'VE WHEN
I HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ITEM. EIGHT TWENTY THREE
FORTY SIX ABSENT MEMBERS
NAZARIAN MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
WENT. WHEN I FLOOR THAT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB TWENTY FOUR TWELVE. ABSENT
MEMBERS NAZARIAN MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I WHEN I WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
ONE ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN.
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I WHEN
NOW. WILL HOLD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS I'M NUMBER ELEVEN AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY THREE ABSENT
MEMBERS IN THIS AREA IN.
MURATSUCHI MERCER GI WHEN I
RUBIO RUBIO HI HOLDEN OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
FIVE ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN.
LEVINE MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I'VE WHEN NOT VOTING WHEN NOT
VOTING. I AM NEVER HOLD IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS I AM THIRTEEN
IS PULLED ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
SB FORTY TWO. ABSENT MEMBERS
NAZARIAN. MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I WHEN. WHEN NO RUBIO RUBIO I
HOLD OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
ADAM SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY TWO OH
ONE ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN.
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I WHEN NO
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS. WELL HOLD
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY OH FIVE
ABSENT MEMBERS NAZARIAN.
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I WHEN I
RUBIO RUBIO HI THANK YOU WILL
HOLD OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND
WE WILL WAIT FOR ONE MORE ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR. THEM CAN I CHANGE
FROM FOR AN ITEM NUMBER. FOR AB
TWENTY ONE ZERO EIGHT NOT VOTING
TO KNOW. THE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY ONE- EIGHT WHEN. NOT
OWNING TEN NO NO. THANK YOU. THE
STATE. I DID VOTE FOR ONE OF
YOUR BILL YES. ONE TWO. THREE I
NEED TO SEE I. YOU CAN. TO
CHANGE YOUR LIFE. OKAY YOUR
MOTION YES. SEVEN YEAH SB SO.
JUST ONE NAZARIAN. DO WE ARE
WORRIED WHERE. FROM I DON'T
THINK THAT'S WHAT GENERAL.
ANYTHING IS SO IT WAS ALWAYS
MISSING OF ALL HERE'S THE THING
ABOUT HIS WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
I THINK YOU CAME OUT WITH YEAH
YEAH YEAH. THANK YOU YEAH
PERFECT. GET. THANK YOU SO. WITH
THE WITH THE RIGHT PRIMARY BUT
WHAT.
ELEVEN CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE ABSENT MEMBER NAZARIAN. HI
NAZARIAN AYE IN THE CALVET. TO
SIX WE HAVE EIGHT. I REMEMBER
ONE EIGHTEEN ELEVEN FROM HERE
FIVE EIGHT. YEAH IT'S EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY THREE THE BILL IS
OUT ITEM NUMBER TWO AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE. EXCEPT THIS AREA AYE. TWELVE AT TWELVE ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. NAZARIAN AYE
. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN FIFTEEN ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT I AM NUMBER FOUR
AB TWENTY ONE OH EIGHT. NAZARIAN
I. ELEVEN TO THREE ELEVEN TO
THREE THE BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER FIVE FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND
NINETEEN OR ON CONSENT- IN.
NINETEEN THAT THE ITEMS FIVE
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND NINETEEN.
NAZARIAN I ON CONSENT. FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN ZERO CONSENT CALENDARS
OUT ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY FIVE. HI NAZARIAN I. FIFTEEN DAYS OR FIFTEEN TO
ZERO THE BILL AS AL ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN.
FROM THE SYRIAN I. FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS AL I AM
NUMBER AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
SIX. NAZARIAN I. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT OF
NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY FOUR
TWELVE NAZARIAN I FIFTEENTH
FIFTEEN TWO ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB. TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY ONE. NAZARIAN FIVE
NAZARIAN I. ELEVEN TO ONE ELEVEN
TO ONE THE BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY THREE. NAZARIAN NOT
VOTING. ELEVEN TO TWO ELEVEN TO
THE BILL IS OUT L. NUMBER TWELVE
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FIVE.
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I. ELEVEN JUST
ELEVEN TO ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN IS PULLED
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB FORTY
TWO. HI IS THERE AND I. FOURTEEN
ONE FOURTEEN TO ONE THE BILL IS
OUT OF NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY TWO OH ONE HI NAZARIAN I. EIGHT TO FIVE EIGHT TO FIVE
THE BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT OH FIVE
. NAZARIAN AYE FIFTEEN FIFTEEN
ZERO AND WITHOUT THE COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.